This is Jocko podcast number
41 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
And tonight we are lucky to
have a guest on the podcast.
My friend,
my teammate,
my brother Tonia fratty and I'm going
to start the podcast by reading a speech
that I wrote when Tony
Retired from the teens.
And for whatever reason,
some reason that I don't remember
it was work or job or some travel or
something.
I couldn't actually be
there to read this myself.
And that's the way the teams is. You
do your job, that's the priority.
And I knew Tony would understand that I
wouldn't be there and it would be no big
deal to him.
And I acted like it was no big deal to me.
But I wanted to be there and I should
have been there in a wrote a speech and
I'm emailed it to one of our,
one of our friends,
one of our Bros, another seal
master chief, and he read it there.
But I should have been
there to read it myself.
And you will hear that this speeches
kind of like Tony is draw
and straightforward and real.
And so here's the speech that I
wrote for Tony when he retired.
Here we go.
First of all,
I apologize to Tony that I couldn't be
there out in the desert today to see you
off.
And for those of you that
are with him today, no,
this Tony a fratty is a hero,
a dirty, scrappy, rough,
hard mean bastard,
but a hero.
I have known him for over 20 years and
in those 20 years I got to see him in
many capacities.
First as a young hardcore beer swilling
muscle car driving machine gunning fist
fighting,
third class petty officer.
Then as an experienced hardcore
Jack Daniels swilling fist fighting,
second class leading petty officer
next as a Badass hardcore fist fighting
knowledge filled,
first class training cell instructor.
And finally as a seal platoon chief and
we all know that being a platoon chief
is supposed to, that you're
hard core. It's supposed to
mean that your experience,
it's supposed to mean that
you're a tough bastard.
It's supposed to mean
that you're fearless.
It's supposed to mean that
you're a true leader of men.
Unfortunately,
we all know
that that isn't always true,
but with Tony,
it's 100% true.
Tony is without question,
the primordial seal chief,
the ultimate senior enlisted leader.
When I joined the teams,
I joined a follow guys like Tony into
unbridled combat into the violent fray
into hell.
Yeah.
I was lucky enough to work with Tony
when he was one of the platoon chiefs in
our task unit and seal team
three from 2005 to 2006
task unit bruiser.
We started our work up here in the desert,
the true forging ground of frog
men with a couple of years on me.
He was the oldest guy in the troop and
therefore the primary representative of
the old breed and he represented
the old breed with honor.
He immediately proved that he was
physically harder, mentally tougher,
and operationally superior
to any of the young bucks.
Really it was August 115 plus degrees.
He didn't get tired.
He out shot everyone.
He ran immediate action
drills like Erwin Rommel.
He didn't drink water seriously.
Coffee in Copenhagen.
That's it and desert training
was just the beginning.
He led every evolution through the entire
workup, always coming up with the plan,
always training and mentoring
the new guys and everyone else.
We trained and we trained hard.
I drew a line in the sand.
Tony held that line.
We pushed the envelope in every
evolution and prepared for war
somehow.
Some way we knew what the future held.
We deployed to Ramadi,
Iraq in April of 2006
and two are absolute joy.
It was an embroiled in a war zone.
We had been on the ground about a
day when I went to meet the brewer,
the brigade commander Toni,
who was already out in the city in a
sniper Overwatch position as I walked into
the brigade tactical operation center
and shook hands with the colonel John
Grotowski.
He said,
one of your snipers just killed an Iud
in place are up on race track where we
lost form four marines three days ago
and that is exactly what he needed
us to do. He needed us to kill them.
That sniper was Tony with the kill of
the deployment strategic due to its
timing,
timing that opened up the entire
battlespace to task unit bruiser.
And so we fought and fought and
killed the enemy by the Bushel.
And Tony was at the front the entire time.
He never wavered.
He never faltered despite
the heat, despite the danger,
despite heavy casualties,
he constantly pushed to get out over and
over and over again to kill the savages
that were determined to destroy
America and coalition forces.
He never asked for a pause or a
break or a night off or a minute off.
Everything that I ever asked of him,
everything he did,
and he did it with every ounce or
commitment and drive and selflessness and
professionalism that any
human could ever muster.
And we would talk and laugh and we
would discuss what we could do better.
And we'd come up with a plan. And in
the end, Tony would give me a head nod.
And that had not meant he had it.
It was done.
He owned it.
And I never doubted that ever.
He never missed an operation and applied
himself to each mission with solemn
gravity.
As the senior enlisted leader,
he poured over maps and imagery.
He held detailed warning orders.
He briefed the platoon with clarity
and directness. He led rehearsals.
He did everything he could do
to be ready in his platoon,
performed magnificently.
Accounting for hundreds of enemy killed
when his own men were wounded or killed
in action. It only fueled his
motivation to kill more of the enemy,
to fight harder to slaughter
more of the evil soul.
This enemy and rid the world
of their wretched kind.
That is what every seal should
aspire to be like. In Tony's words,
BTF a big tough frog man with no fear,
no hesitation and no mercy.
Just be to BTF through
everything like Tony did
for senior chief of Friday's courage,
determination, and leadership.
I will be eternally grateful.
I owe him more than I can ever
repay him for what he did for me,
for the task unit,
for the teams and for our great nation.
Let there be no doubt the
man before you as a hero,
the teams or a worse place without his
presence, his guidance, his leadership,
his example,
those that served with him must strive
to carry the torch and pass it on so that
his spirit burns bright
in the team's forever.
I recently watched a movie about,
let me kill sister,
the lead,
the leader of the original
classic heavy metal thrash band,
Motorhead, the movie
chronicles, the life of Lemmy,
the hard living,
rock and roll legend.
The movie paints a picture of a
unique individual that will never,
that can never exist again.
The movie is called Lemmy,
49% motherfucker,
51% son of a bitch.
And that seems to suit,
let me pretty well
and I'm not exactly sure how those
numbers would break out for Tony,
but I do know this,
Tony a fratty is 100% frogman
always was and always will be.
Tony, thanks for everything.
I'll see you on the other side.
BTF Jocko.
And with that Tony,
thanks for coming on the show.
Thanks a lot brother. Kinda forgot about
that. Yeah. And that was, that was good.
And the guy, we're talking about
reddit pretty good too. And yeah,
I didn't have like a
big ceremony or nothing.
He just went out the nylon and we get
all gummed up and that was about it. But,
uh,
I do, I appreciate it man. Yeah,
it's good to see you brother.
It's good seeing you too.
And you know, actually, uh,
when I told people that you
were coming on the show,
Yo people actually know who you
are from the lift to tell. Oh yeah.
And uh, Lafe Lafe spit on here.
We talked about you, you know,
told some stories and shit. And so, uh,
but a bunch of people had a
bunch of questions and you know,
I figured we try and get
through some of them.
We won't be able to answer
all the ones that I got,
but I picked out some of them and uh,
let you take a look and pick
out some of them. So, well,
I mean, first and foremost,
people just want to know kind of who the
hell are you and where'd you come from?
As funny a few years back, like, uh,
we're all in Arizona and I took a bunch
of the guys in the platoon over to my
parents' house. No, we had SAPA
and everyday is a wicked fun.
Jeremy Pulls me aside and he's like,
you're actually have parents.
I thought you were born round or a
rock somewhere in the desert. I'm like,
shut up. You know, that
was pretty funny. Now I'm,
I'm from New Hampshire and uh,
all right.
It's just probably like you just,
yeah,
it's not so much wanting to be a seal.
I just want to be something different.
You know? I could have went like a biker
gang or something just as easy, you know,
you know,
I figured if this,
I have a pretty good chance of staying
out of the clinic, you know, this way.
But not always,
but a few times,
you know,
that's fair.
But it teams just suited me because
everybody's the same. Everybody,
you know,
every where you look,
guys are doing what you would do
and they act how you would act.
And it's not always great.
But you know, so you,
you got recruited though by some of the
boys, like over in the Pi, didn't you?
Yeah, I mean, I wanted be abuse you,
but I wasn't like thousand percent now
and I was in the Philippines and I was
like, all right, I gotta
do that. That's it.
So I went and got a screening test
over there in Subic Bay and you know,
I smoked it and I then, you know, they
didn't have this long pipeline back then.
I got there on a Friday,
we've got all gummed up and shaved their
heads on Sunday and we started Monday.
There was not that was it just
okay, go. Well actually I know, uh,
I was talking to the old master chief
that actually was the guy that recruited
you and told you you need
to be a team guy. And me,
I was talking to her the other day when
you were down at his house on the phone.
Yeah. But uh, yeah. And he was one
of my platoon chief says, you know,
but I told him,
I told him the best thing he ever did
for the teams was get you to enjoy the
that's he was laughing.
He probably probably like,
well definitely the best thing for you.
You know how saved your ass from all
kinds of try. Absolutely. But it's just,
you know,
it's the team's like between us,
we got like 46 years a team guy life.
And uh,
it's so hard to put in perspective.
If you don't all you talk, you know,
you've never been there. No people
like, people don't know that.
We don't call each other seals. Yeah. You
never say that. You never, nobody says,
when I joined the navy seals, I
was like, when I became a team guy,
I say that everyone just
like turned her head go.
It's come on really weird when you hear
a team guy referred to being a navy seal
actually makes you think,
well wait, wait a second. Who,
this guy must not have
actually been in the class.
Are you in your immediate interrogation?
Like,
what would your Hancock behind your back?
Like I'm just gonna it's gonna hit him.
So I'd give his driver's license. A
black guy. I don't know where that,
I don't know where that comes from.
Like where we don't say it.
I guess maybe it's, I don't, when I
got the team water it was like, Oh,
you don't talk about it. Yeah. You don't
say it. No. I don't know. Stickers.
No t shirts. No. No. You don't
do any of that. I'm sure.
All the honorable punishable by death.
You don't, you don't say anything. Well,
we all thought we were going to Vietnam
the next day. He's like, oh my God.
And after awhile you're like, all
right. What's happening here? Yeah.
Good. All right man. Well, so that's,
Tony grew up in New England like me.
And you know, did you ever hear this?
That they spent a bunch of money
trying to figure out who's training?
The only, literally the
only thing they got was, uh,
guys that wrestled and guys
from New England and it
wasn't like a big difference.
But you know,
a normal person has a 26% chance of
making it through and someone from New
England had like a 37 or something like
a small uptick. I think. You know what?
I think also that
there's good people out on the country,
don't get me wrong, but New England
as a pretty strong work ethic,
you know what I mean? Yeah.
I've seen that a lot. A lot.
And not that other people
don't. Yeah, but all the guys,
mostly guys I moved from New England
and the teams that are pretty good work
ethic. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it just cold to too. So that
doesn't help. That doesn't matter.
I think it does, cause I thought
guys from Florida in my class,
like dude's these kids from Florida,
there was a couple of kids from
Florida and they will, you know,
all loud and like they
were just big tough guys,
but they were already in the teams
basically in their own minds and they all
Kuwait,
I know well the first day of buds and
looking around some of these guys and
they're like, wow, holy crap,
these guys are like insane
shape and all this stuff.
I'm still hung over from the Pii,
you know,
and I, you know, I made it
and like they didn't, it's,
it's weird,
you know,
they just had this kid that quit buds and
then he went and jumped off of a hotel
down in San Diego, killed himself
and I looked at a picture of that.
He missed the pool or something.
No, there was no pool to jump into.
He killed himself and he did it right.
I succeeded.
But I was looking at him. I was
talking to, uh, one of the guy,
the guy that we know who's
an instructor over there.
And I was looking at a picture of
the dude and the dude was like,
distrapting guy,
all buff plot air.
It just looked like a total stud. And I
go, man, that kind of looked like a stud.
What happened? And then the
instructor guide said, dude,
they all look like that now.
Like everybody's just, you
know, it's a big deal. Hey,
I'm going to go on the seal teams,
I'm going to go on the seal teams.
And that's what they're saying.
So they're recruiting is really easy.
But the recruiting all these studs world,
but it doesn't matter.
The attrition rate stays the
same. Yeah, that's what you know,
you know that the government
wants more and more teen guns.
It just ain't going to happen. No, it's
not. Not unless you lower the standards.
And if that happens, then we've all
not done our job. That's just terrible.
Awesome. All right, get some
of these questions here. Um,
it says here on the first podcast
with leaf, you discussed the story,
which Tony came up with a strategy for an
op and totally, totally food be better.
The brief would be better
coming from life. And it says,
where did you develop this humility
and this characteristic of not worrying
about individual credit
versus p team objectives.
So to rehash that story real
quick, it was real, we were out at,
we were out at the desert training
facility and we were just planning,
you plan something like you don't
want to do iteration training,
we just gotta go down and go to,
there was one just one of those and
they changed the target or something.
And you're like, okay, here's what
we need to do. Put guys over here,
putting Overwatch over here and walked
through online like this and lay like,
hey, sounds good to go. Why don't
you get the guys over and brief them?
And you said, hey sir, you know what,
you go ahead and brief them that way it
sounds better coming from you and that'd
be the way to do it. And he was like,
well all right. You know, he was,
he was fired up and I, when I
saw you do that, I was like,
cause cause this is the thing,
and I forgot to mention this,
you and I have known each
other for a long time.
We both held for ad together and,
and we had the same friends and
we hung out at the same places,
but we were never in a platoon together.
Nope. We never in a platoon together.
It never worked together,
like directly together until
we were in tasking at bruiser.
So when I got denial and I
knew you reputation, which was,
which was rock solid,
but I don't trust anybody
about anybody size cus not yes.
So I, so I just, you know,
so I'm seeing you kind of for the first
time out there of actually working and
you know, that was a big indicator
to me. I was like, Damn, you know,
this guy is totally humble,
wants to make as officer look good,
wants to make, which is only
gonna make the platoon better.
It's only going to make everybody
better. So yeah, that was awesome.
And what a great attitude to have. And I
get asked that all the time. People get,
you know, my bosses is doing this
and what should I do? I'm like, well,
give them support. Try and help them.
Yeah. Try and make them look good.
But the thing is chewing away at people
is their ego of them walk the credit and
you see this up, do you mean you can
we see this all the time and the lips.
So anyways,
where did you realize that?
Did anybody teach you that
or where the hell did you,
how the hell did you know to do that?
I can read and watch people pretty good.
And I watched some guys who kind
of brought me up in the teams,
some of the guys we were talking about
earlier and I tried to kind of mimic
them, but then it kind of morphs into
your own shit, you know? Nope. And uh,
well yeah, the first thing is I was
just tired and my voice was gone.
I just wanted him to do it.
I'm just kidding.
So tired, so tired. But uh, yeah,
like get over their boss and do your job.
But I mean,
some of them guys in that, that
platoon, they were already my chums,
like Chris Kyle and Bob and Jeremy and
them guys who've been around a while and
they already know.
I put them through training and then land
warfare on an island. So they're there.
They know me, you know,
and up to that point,
that's when I was doing a lot of that
shit. And I'm like, no boss, you do it.
Because basically he's new to them,
not doing the teams,
but he was new and I figured he's got
to do this more and more and more. Yeah.
You know, and, and he did of course, you
know, life stepped up like, uh, like, uh,
you know,
gangbusters and just great officer.
But then beginning stages like,
all right,
I've already done this a million times. I
don't, I don't care. I'm good. You know,
you want my advice, but we'll come
on. Let's just get the ball rolling.
Nice to do it. And so if that answers the
question. Yeah, no, that, that was, uh,
and again,
that was always an attitude you had,
which was he never cared
about looking good yourself.
And part of that is you just had such a
good reputation in the teams that what
are you going to do with look even better?
Yeah, like again, another navy calmer
but, but you know a lot of people, so if
you're listening and you're wondering,
you know,
what makes,
what makes somebody a good like a
good NCO and it was a lot of marines,
a lot of soldiers listen to this.
What makes a good NCO?
You don't always have
to make yourself shine.
You don't always have to be the
guy that's the center of attention.
And as a matter of fact,
generally that shines through as being
a guy that wants to be the center of
attention instead of a guy that wants to
have a good bill tune and it's not like
it was doing it to make rank and
expect to make e five nevermind.
Senior chief.
Uh,
all right,
next question.
Please detail the way you were able to
use decentralized command when running
task unit bruiser and how it was
met through the other commanders.
So for those of you that don't know,
decentralized command means you're going
to let your subordinate leadership lead
and you're not going to
micromanage everybody. And
that's definitely what I did.
And I didn't micromanage well I should,
I should rephrase that.
We have people need to be micromanaged.
All micromanage them.
If they're jacked up,
I'm going to be all in them.
And exactly like you're talking about
with life in, with Seth and or with, uh,
the other platoon,
the Delta between commander.
I micromanage those guys like crazy when
we first got in because I'm just making
sure they were good to go just
because they work that experience.
I'm just like guys that don't trust
anybody when you don't know. Yeah.
And then,
uh,
but their goal was to just have them be
able to run on their own and make stuff
happen. Because I'll tell
you another thing, you can't,
you can't run everything yourself.
Nobody can know.
And so you got a decentralized command.
And that's what I did was I let
you know when we got on deployment,
I wasn't micromanaging anything. I was
barely, I was just kind of broad guidance,
you know? Right. Of cost and then,
and then you guys were running the
stuff and making things happen. I mean,
I would've loved to be on every operation,
but I physically couldn't because
we had multiple ops going on.
We had to split forces.
So what are you going to do?
I've got no problems with anyone in that
group. The lowest guy running an op. Yup.
But you got,
you got to let you gotta let the boys
basically screw up because then you don't
know how they're gonna react.
Okay.
Do they just sit there and power moo
and then you've got to slap mortar or do
they, okay, here's what
you did wrong, Roger that.
And then immediately start
thinking how to fix it.
Cause everybody fucks up
everything. What's facing, I mean,
we were never always good at anything.
Stilling really good at much.
There's BTF through it all. And so it
doesn't seem like we made mistakes.
I mean really,
but leadership is funny because some
guys take to it like water and other guys
are scared to death of it. Yeah. You know,
lately I've been realizing that
because people always say, you know,
our leaders made or born and can you make
a person that's not a good leader into
a good leader? And I look
at it kind of like, um,
when you see these video games where
people have different strengths and
weaknesses and in a guy might be a strong
and high intellect and good agility
and I don't know, whatever
those games, hair posture. Yeah.
So with leadership at the same thing,
cause there's certain elements,
certain natural things that you can
have that make you a good leader,
for instance, is a real simple
one. Can you be loud in,
in the seal teams, if you
can't be loud, that's gonna be,
that's gonna be a problem. If you can't
just take control of a room and be like,
you know, hey everyone get in this
world. You know, you can't do that.
People can hear you. Then you've got
to find a way around that. Right.
Are You articulate?
Can you simplify things that are complex?
There's all these little things that you
get ranked, you basically all ranked at,
and some guys have,
they were born low rankings and they
either find a way to make up for them,
they learn how to do them better or
they compensate by using somebody else.
You know, if like I wasn't
loud, I'd be like, Hey Tony,
tell everyone to get in here. Then
you can do it. Right. All right. Uh,
that makes total sense though.
If someone out there is a leader,
have been in a leadership position, you
know, exactly they talking about. Yup.
And then sometimes it's, you know, hey,
what's the problem? Oh really? What's
the problem? Whoa. Okay. Like you said,
good, good. All right. Now you've
identified, go work it out.
Don't sit around and cry about
it and just go do it, you know?
And then you've got five minutes.
Yeah, yeah. We'll take care of it.
I think the other thing with
decentralized command, it's,
that's important is for everybody
didn't know what the limits are,
like how far you can go and
right direction or another.
And I know that, you know,
like I was trusted you guys were
going to do the right thing. Well,
like you said early on in that workup,
you know, leadership at every level.
And even the junior guy,
it's his responsibility to keep me in
check if something's going wrong because
if I'm doing something stupid,
he's like, Hey Tony, what? Oh yeah.
Okay. I lost it there for a while cause
sometimes I'm old, sometimes I lose it.
And once in a while, you know,
and I'm not gonna apologize.
Yeah. Nice. Anything else
on decentralized command?
Well,
it's,
it's a lot easier if you start right from
the beginning trying to make everybody
understand decentralized command.
Cause that's the goal. Yeah.
It has to be the goal.
Someone like you,
you can't, you gotta be
somewhere else. You know, we,
we didn't want you on the
battlefield with this.
I wanted you on a battlefield with me
every time you where I was like, oh,
this is awesome. I mean, I really, really
needed you back where you are. Of course,
you know, and that is it. Everybody
had a wicked high level of confidence.
Just knowing that you were
back there taking care of
watching her back, you know,
and never sleeping and just
doing like 40 pull ups,
sweating and,
and trying to eat everything in the camp.
Yeah, yeah. It's a,
it the, the thing that you talk about as
far as getting everyone to know that and
understand that from the beginning
is, is for sure. Oh yeah.
I mean everybody's got to know that man,
you know,
I don't want like my favorite thing is
I go out on an operation with you guys
and not do anything. Now you would
just shoot around the shooter. Okay.
I'm just in the train.
All the, you know, that's,
that's the way it should be because the
leaders are leading cause life is doing
his job. He's leading the
assembly's leaving things, the,
the breach team is doing their
stuff and I'm just like, okay, cool.
I'm basically an observer, you know,
now to a point. Yeah. And you're like,
all right,
I always the data,
but uh, but that's the
way you want it, you know?
And then when something does happen,
you can then handle it.
You can step in and go, okay, hey guys,
we need to back off over here, right?
This is, this is going wrong. And,
and that's the way it should be.
So if that's your goal though, is to
say, look, I want my leaders to lead.
I don't want to be doing all their
job for them when, first of all,
that'll make them more confident.
It'll make them more capable.
And then when something does happen,
they, and they need your assistance.
You're not bogged down with something
else, you can step in and make it happen,
right?
Dick?
It's a take like Iraq or Afghanistan.
That's what combat vets coming back and
they talk about decentralized command.
It's important because if you're just
doing the same like army training and an
army unit goes over there, what are
they going to do? Go, all right guys.
Now we're doing decentralized
command later, you know, you know,
until that happens, you know you've
got gotta now they come back, hey,
we need to train like this. Yup. Here's
a lot of junior officers need to do.
Here's our answer. You always need to do,
here's how are you fives or you fours,
you know, our privates, there's
what they need to do. Yep. Good.
All right, next up. Uh,
okay.
T talk about some failures in planning
leadership and how you built back up.
Yeah, we didn't, we had none of
that. Everything went perfect.
You're one of the things that
I think of winning and I,
I guess it was really a failure,
but we would
often times make a decision and then
in a day or in a week decide yeah,
that wasn't a good call.
Lean over to somebody else.
And I think a good example of that is how
we kind task organized and we split up
into different groups and be like,
okay, you guys are running this area,
you guys run in this area. And then
like two weeks later, actually no,
this area is not good.
We're gonna move the guys who
have joined them back together.
I always felt like everybody, especially
us in the leadership, you know,
we were all like, okay, cool.
Yeah, we just made a mistake.
We just move on. Let it,
not, not even a mistake, but you gotta
change. You gotta adapt. Yeah, you go,
you got to morph into something.
It's like if you're doing unilateral lots,
then it's kind of a no brainer.
If you go over there and all of a sudden
you know, all you working by yourself,
boom, boom, doing your missions, great.
But if you work in Split
forces in your training,
indigenous forces and you're doing
that, you have to have these, you know,
you have to,
it's not always easy to adjust for it
because it's like there's a world of
difference between Iraq and Afghanistan.
Like a world of difference.
I mean it's all kind of the same but
stuff I did in Iraq and Afghanistan,
you know, and vice versa, like,
whoa, can't do that. You know?
And even even stuff like the
weather, you know, talking don't,
all of a sudden it's snowing,
you know, and then the terrain,
like people think our axle does it.
I mean,
there were some places where
they were like, in the jungle,
it's like we were in Nam, you know,
Cambodia crate shakes. And I'm like,
well we wouldn't, you know,
okay, we're going to walk.
How many clicks? Yeah. Well,
when you're up do waist in mud and all
of a sudden that timeframe is totally
off. Cause we didn't, you know,
made a mistake. I didn't really,
really read the terrain,
you know,
and ask about it and she has been
up there before and shit. But yeah.
But we just adapt and overcome.
Exactly.
I think that's a biggest learn from
your mistakes when it comes to failure.
It's just, okay, what do I do
now? Yeah. Good. Okay. Let's,
let's adapt and move on.
Yep. Alright. Um, next one.
I really want to hear you talk about
the battlefield and how it made you feel
and the type of situations
when the shit hits the fan.
Well,
I kind of questions pretty easy for
me how the battle field made me feel.
All I can say is that made me feel much
better than any other place than the
battlefield. You know what I mean? Yeah.
Cause everything makes sense on the
battlefield very either going forward or
getting going away or defending
our position or moving out. Yeah.
Out of that, what else is there?
Because all of them things,
even if you have men down
and people wanted, you still
gotta do them. Yeah. Well,
as I sit here and think about this,
so our optempo was very high,
meaning the operational type below.
For those of you that
don't know what that means,
it means like how often you're doing work
and the op tempo was very high and so,
but sometimes for whatever reason,
let's say an operation would get cancelled
or pushback and all of a sudden Tony
would have been in camp for like
two days. Well, the second day,
like the first day he'd be, you know,
okay. He's coming up with plans,
looking at something else,
you know him and lay for trying to figure
something out to do. But then the SEC,
by the second day, he's just just starting
to get all frustrated place around.
Well, hey is this is just
stupid. Yeah. Oh, what's next?
We're going to go to like the big
base and like country music concert or
something so serious.
Like when I flew into a Canada.
Yeah. And he's guys like, Oh,
you just missed,
I can't remember what countries
did they go to concerts and stuff.
I'm eating rat shit stuff up in the
mountains, you know? I'm like, really?
We all of these people doing here?
Why aren't you a murderer and the bad guy?
God, yeah. So Tony,
you would get very frustrated after like
two days and then you just come in and
I'd say, okay dude, here, just gold
this area and go find something to do.
And then you'd go make a plan and
you'd leave for come back. All right,
we got something more. You
going to go get it. But you got,
you got to admit though, uh, you know,
time off is not such a good thing.
I mean, a couple day's break down now and
then, but you got to keep the boys busy.
Then they start thinking and
they start getting, you know,
but I mostly did it for me cause
I just wanted to get after.
Yeah, there's definitely, you can
smoke them, but uh, you're right.
If all of a sudden they're sitting around
all the time, they is, uh, what's that?
Uh,
a body in motion tends to stay in motion
and a body at rest room since to stay
at rest of you start lagging and all of
a sudden you're going to go do an op and
everyone's Kinda, there's resistance.
There's not, not, not verbal resistance,
just just like shrug the shoulders.
Just like a resistance of some unseen
resistance in the world that wants you to
slow down. But when the shit
hits the fan, you know, it's,
it's strange because it makes
me like a little calmer I think.
I mean, not always. I had the
first, first time I ever got shot,
I was a little jittery a little bit, but
you know, oh my God, what's going on?
Actually I knew what it was, you
know, it's not like, Ooh, what's that?
Actually I actually remember you were
a briefing, some of the guys when we,
when we were back and you were like,
um, you were like, Hey, you know what?
We didn't work on training. When, when I,
when we went through training and
we're getting ready to go to Ramadi,
we didn't work on, on, on this
right here. What's happening.
Yeah, there's this too. Oh Wow.
This is going to be cool. Yeah.
Till all that bad stuff starts.
Then there's screaming, yelling,
diving into shit, shooting and killing
them. But you know, it's Kinda,
it is fun. Uh, yeah. Uh, yeah.
I think the thing I've said on
here before is that the battlefield
and all these situations,
they just give you this clear focus in
life that nothing else gives you now.
Well, nothing that I've
found through this. Like, oh,
we're going to kill people are
going to get killed ourselves.
That's everything in the world.
Nothing else matters. No, that's it.
Just like sitting in camp,
watching TV. That doesn't matter.
Okay. You got your rest.
You okay? You good?
All right. Now let's go. Uh,
all right.
Next one.
Not to take away from the seriousness of
what you to have achieved in the seals,
but I would like Tony to tell a funny
story about Jocko and reason I put this
one in here. Uh, of course,
I don't like to hear any humor
or any laughter in the world,
but there was a bunch of people that,
that said this. So, uh, anyways,
I figured you might have a store here.
I got like,
like seriously, like a million,
like a million. I mean,
that story about you and your
roommate. Like you're, uh, you're like,
you guys live together in Coronado.
Yeah. You know what I'm talking about?
The big fella, you're like,
oh, it's over there, patty.
In one night we're getting gooned
up and you're like, you know,
what are our bill was from dominoes.
It's like $2,500 last month in a month.
But that was so funny. He had some
wicked good parties though. Yeah,
we did have some pretty good.
And then one time we were out at a
Niland and it's like two o'clock in the
morning and the guys are,
you know,
they're a retail, we call that after
you'd done do the work on the vehicles,
uh, post, you know, post off the vehicle,
stopping the vehicles and they're
all busy doing stuff. And, I mean,
I'd help out if I had to, but I
mean that's not my job. Yeah. So,
and they boys know what to do.
Jeremy had him great Lpo and uh,
we're sitting here,
me,
you and life and maybe one or the other
gos shooting the shit about something.
I mean,
it had to do at work because there's what
else is there and life was talking and
there's quiet kinda and you got your
am on one of the Humvees and all of a
sudden you're just out of no way. He
just kicked the dirt and you go, God,
you're like shaking your head and
clutching your fish. I'm like,
fuck you talking about. And he just like
looked at me and smiled and walked away.
Like, what? What, what is wrong with you?
Still haven't figured out what
was wrong with you. I know,
I remember he just went,
no,
I was actually getting frustrated that
there was a chance we might not go to
Iraq.
They didn't like,
I was so scared and horrified of,
of that. It just, you know, and
I just was trying to control it,
but then it just kind of slipped out.
Oh, here's another quick one about Jacko.
I'm like,
I dunno,
we were there a couple of weeks and
Ramadi and we've just fallen into what
groove operating.
And One night I was in his office
cause like couldn't sleep or whatever.
And uh, he's like, look at this and
you show me, he shows me the computer.
He goes, this is from
my wife. Are you okay?
You've been gone three weeks
and we haven't heard anything
baby. I'm like, Chum, you better.
You better email your wife or
she's going to fly over, kill you.
Yeah. Yeah. I uh hmm. Yeah,
I talk about detachment a lot
and uh, sometimes, you know,
like I said,
sometimes you get over there and you
got all that shit going on and uh,
nothing else in the world matters.
But I didn't have anything going on
back here. Didn't matter to me at all.
Sorry. Uh, uh, to my wife
there, uh, for not she,
I'm sure she remembers that you in any
way you did though. You're like, okay,
I got it. Yeah. Uh, all right.
Here's one.
What made you realize one of your guys
was really good to go or was not up to
standard?
Not necessarily big things,
but micro actions or decisions that
set something off in your mind?
Well, I had a lot of guys work on
me over the years and, and I mean,
I really think that, you know,
all my brothers and the teams,
every one of them was good to go.
Even the guys that didn't get along with,
I'd still get my wife for him in a second,
doesn't matter.
But one thing that sticks out to me
was biggles but knows Brian job as,
you know, I don't, I guess I could
have been more nice or whatever,
but I'm like, man, you look
like you're fucking fat.
You better get in fucking shape where
I'm going, I'm going to fucking kill you.
I'm not going to like write you up.
I don't even know how to do that.
I'm going to, I'm going to just
physically kill you and man, you know,
I didn't even know if he was in good
shape or not because some people you can't
tell. Yeah. And they like look at that
guy and then he just knocks you out.
They have people that iron marshmallow.
Yeah. And man, that kid did. I mean,
he really, really did. And like
all of a sudden I'm like, Chum,
I didn't say that. I was like, hmm.
I, you know, so that was like, yeah,
that was like my praise.
I, you know, yeah.
Whatever you kind of praise from today on
the next one, on to the next thing now.
But I mean, that was
really good. You know,
I remember one of my guys,
uh,
lost a piece of equipment one time and
know all, I was kind of upset with him,
but it just made me realize that,
you know,
if we're making a mistake, maybe it's not
this guy's fault, maybe it's my fault.
Maybe it's everyone's fault as, as a
team. Because at the end of the day,
it's all of us say maybe what
to take a day or two off,
you know, and that kind of help
and we handled it. But I mean,
and another one of my guys, he
uh, was Christmas when you left,
left a piece of equipment open
or didn't lock something or,
I mean it wasn't a big deal.
I could have corrected it right there,
but the guys had just taken
off on Christmas leave and
I was dead nowhere where
to go.
So I was drinking beers and the team area
and I just walked around checking shit
out and sure enough,
so I called the guy and he was like
three or 400 miles into his drive to a
western state for Christmas. And like,
he goes, oh, I'm sorry. I'm like, yeah,
no problem man. All right, so turn
around now and I'll be waiting for you.
Is Dead Silence on the phone
usually what? Yeah. Yeah.
So he drove all the way back
and I was standing there,
it's like four in the morning now.
And I was like,
I was pretty liquored up by then. And
just fuming, but, and he's like, Hey,
I'm sorry when lesson. Yup.
Okay. Have a good lead.
And I'm sure I'm positive he never did
that again. That'll do it, you know,
as kind of a dink move I guess. But you
know, I figured it was a thing to do.
He who suffers, remembers. Yeah.
Yeah. It's, it's
the, the, the, the seal teams when you're,
when you're just working
with guys all the time,
you definitely start to pick up
things. You can indicate, okay, yeah,
this guy's this guy stepping up. You
know? That's what I always noticed when,
when things are going sideways,
like in a training operation and you
see a guy that's starting to step up,
you know, that was always a good sign.
Absolutely. You know, like he's going to,
he's going to handle
something like sweet trained,
decentralized command and that's where
you got to let guys make mistakes and
screw things up because you know,
the less you know,
the more you sweat and training,
the less you bleed in war.
No doubt about that one. All right. Um,
next one,
Tony,
where their situations while in Iraq
when you disagreed with a leadership
decision made by leaf or Jocko,
if so,
how did you express your disapproval
and were you successful in getting your
point across?
Um, most of the time, 99% of the time, no,
I did not.
Uh,
there was one big one that I really
disagree with you guys on when my,
uh,
my request to keep the entire troop there
for another year and said he couldn't
and I try, why not? And you're
like, we can't. And I'm like, why?
And I was really, really, really
angry about that. But yeah, I think,
I think this,
this question here is,
is,
is from someone that's thinking that
doesn't really understand how working,
you know, in the bottom line is, I'm not
coming down and going, all right men,
this is what I want you to do now. No,
we would just form our own operations.
Just all,
we're forming our own operations and
we're all kind of bouncing ideas off each
other. The best idea rises to the
top. I don't care who it came from.
I don't care if it came from me,
Tony from one of the new guys,
it doesn't matter to me where the idea
comes from or where the plan comes from.
I want the best idea to rise to the top.
And that's one of the best things about
our troop was there was no one that was
like trying to drive their own
personal point. I didn't care.
I literally didn't care. And I think
part of it is like you and me just said,
plan so many operations and he just, you
know, we just didn't care. It's like, oh,
that's cool. Yeah, yeah, that
sounds like a good plan. You know,
made me make this adjustment. Maybe make
that adjustment. Other than that, cool,
let's execute it. Yeah. So I think
that's a little bit different than, um,
than what people would envision as like,
I was law called Mander or,
or because we're just not
operating like that now.
This is why I've said to people very flat,
even though there's,
even though that the
military and the seal teams,
and there's definitely a hierarchy
or you'll structure, I mean,
that's the way it's organized. There's
a the troops and then there's, you know,
leading petty officers.
And then there's a platoon chief,
then there's a platoon
commander, then there's a, uh,
a troop commander or a task unit
commander and there's a, a team.
So there's a structure
there, customers. But the,
as far as how we actually come to plan
and stuff like that, there's, yeah,
I mean some guidance, but we're working
as a team to do that. And that's what,
and I would say it's not always like that.
In fact,
I know it's not always like that cause I
saw their platoons and other troops act
and do different ways.
But we did operations that came
from our commanding officer.
Seal team three came all the way down.
Yup.
And some of them were wicked good hop,
except they'd give the,
maybe the mission objective,
but they wouldn't be telling us
like go in here and all customers,
we would never, well that's not the
way it works. So I think that, uh,
I mean this situations,
when you disagreed with me,
it was probably in one hand you could
say never end. And the other hand,
you could say a million times you were
like, no man, we shouldn't do that.
And I'd be like, well, why not?
Oh, we should put the vehicles
in here. Oh, okay. Yeah.
That's a good point. Yeah.
So that's, that's how we
voiced it by saying, Oh yeah,
let's do this. So I was like,
oh, okay, cool. Yeah. That's
good. Sounds good though.
Big, big, big. Uh, what's that?
Like a big soap opera leadership
struggle. No, not, not happening.
That never happened.
And uh,
so if you don't have that kind of
relationship with people, number one,
is it your own ego getting involved?
Because that's probably, that's,
that's a good indicator if you're
like, well, you know what though,
my subordinates just don't understand.
Oh really? Yeah. Really? Why not? Okay.
Why not suck as a leader
then just do it like good.
You know? Maybe, maybe if
you did better they wouldn't,
they wouldn't understand the mission.
So
pretty flat organization we had, at least
from a planning perspective. Yes sir.
All right.
If you had to pick
one driving characteristic that
separates a dominant Alpha team guy from
everyone else,
what in the team?
What is it? Well, it's guys in
the teams, you got to know this,
but a lot of people out there don't that
like pretty much everyone's an Alpha
Male, you know? There you go. It's like
nobody gives up the argument ever,
you know? And usually it's, you know,
wrestling or fighting and he's
[inaudible] it always works itself out.
But I think, uh, one thing I we
were talking about is gimmicks.
Like a lot of people in the teams,
I call it a gimmick,
everybody's good at everything,
pretty much and does the job.
But some people are like just insane.
Skydivers some guys are just
phenomenal rock climbers.
Some guys who just like
swimming, sons of guns, you know,
runners and wrestlers and
fist fighters and you know,
some people just in the guns. I
mean that, that's their passion.
Some people are just phenomenal
divers, you know? And I was,
I was always pretty good at
everything, but not great. You know,
I couldn't outrun everybody. I could
not fight everybody. I could not swim,
everybody could know, shoot
everybody. And I just, I,
I think mine was like tactics and
just being as hard as I could and it,
it, I had, I may have made it look easy,
but it was, and especially as I got older,
it's no fun being a team guy
when you're 44, you know,
and you get up and be
like, all right. Yeah.
Okay.
Then I'm like,
I better retire. I'm done with
all this. But yeah, if that,
if that Kinda makes sense. Yeah. And
the other funny thing about that is, um,
because of the teams,
no team guy ever wants to give any
credit to a different team guy.
So if someone was like, Hey, you know
that, that guys are really good shot.
And then someone immediately by, yeah.
You don't know how to swim though. Yeah.
We used to talk about always just like,
someone's always really weird.
No one's good at everything.
Did you work? Did you,
and if they can't figure something out,
they'll be like, whatever. Fuck that guy.
They'll just walk away. Hey,
wait, wait. Yeah. Yeah. The, uh,
you know, one thing I'll say that is
pretty cool and I already brought this up.
Like one of the things that,
that
separate,
like w w when I worked,
we've got first time I saw you like
being humble. I was like, man, that's,
that to me is the characteristic that
you can tell the guy is not just a good
team guy, but an awesome team guy when
he's humble about what's going on.
And when I was putting
guys through training,
and I know you saw this to the guys
that would come through training that
thought they were all bad ass and
thought they couldn't do anything wrong,
they were always bad. Like they
never did a good job. Right. Right.
And then the guys that were
say, hey man, I'm, you know,
I'm looking forward to the training. I
know we need, we need to get tuned up and,
and uh, let you know, let me,
don't know what I can do better.
Those guys were there taking notes.
They always kicked ass.
They always do a good job.
Yeah.
So that being humble is a
well being humbled to is
I read a bunch of after action report,
you know in my tours over there about
different situations, different things.
And every time they were well
written by some guys, but it was,
you'll always carry this, you will always
do this. Never do this, always do that.
And I kinda took that into account when
I wrote it like a serious after action
report for that deployment.
I wish you would have saved it too is
it's pretty good. So first and foremost,
this is what worked for us in
these months, this environment,
this temperature with this mission set
and what we had to do, don't use this as,
oh he said that. So I'm going to do it
every time. No, I mean use it as a guide.
Every,
everything that teams is a toolbox.
You pick it out when you need it and
you use it and you put it back away.
And if it sits in there 500 years,
it's still worth having because of timing.
Pull it out. You didn't really need it.
Yup. Yup. Next one
in the teams.
What were the biggest reputation?
Builders or killers?
And for those of you who
don't know in the teams,
and I guess it's the same anywhere, but
it definitely is true in the teams, man,
your reputation is, uh, is
everything. It's everything.
And people know who you are.
They know if you do something stupid
and they're like a really stupid,
and the teams, as everybody knows,
everyone knows it forever. Yeah. Yeah.
Like, uh, if you have
an accidental discharge,
we meaning meaning if you shoot your
gun when you weren't supposed to,
and there may be some scenarios where
there's a little bit of leeway on that,
but if you just do it,
no dumps situation,
everybody's gonna know about it forever.
And it's just like,
you might as well just get a tattoo
on your forearm that says, Hey,
I had an AED on this date. Even
forehead, if you do something stupid,
you know, something that could get you
in trouble. Like just dumb. Yeah. You're,
you're probably gonna just
everyone's going to know about it.
They're always going to think about it.
If you get,
if you get fired from a position and
you happen to not get kicked out of the
teams, everybody's going to, everybody
knows it'll just get out. Yup.
Yeah. It's, it's,
it's a tough community when it comes
to reputation and so it's really,
it's wicked brutal. Like, yeah. You
know, every, it's like a small town.
Everybody knows everything even though
you're on other coasts. Yep. I mean,
I've done a lot of stupid shit in my
career and I was a jerk off and dumb,
dumb stuff and been an idiot and
everybody knows all that. Yeah. You know?
Yeah.
You know,
most of the stuff that you
did fortunately is kind of a,
is like on the okay side out of, I don't
know, I don't know how to explain this,
but like, oh, oh yeah, Tony,
he got drunk and got in a
fight at this thing and you're
like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's almost made a big spectacle and too
big to do with the uniforms and stuff.
Wouldn't it have to do with like the
things that you kind of can't do or you
can't get away with her?
It'll affect your reputation in a bad way.
Wouldn't it have more to do with how
good of a team that you are and know what
you're right. You're just called
her. I know what it has to do with,
is it something that has that helped or
is it something that is operational or
not? Yeah, operational.
Everybody knows like if you,
I mean even like you'll hear about a guy
that gets lost in buds in you or like
gets lost going through the initial
training when he got to the team,
he gets on land on land navigation
and gets lost. It has to get rescued.
That's just going to stick
with you for ever like,
like I remember,
you know,
I remember getting like three briefs
about some guy that I was getting in a
platoon about where this guy got
lost, how stupid it was. You know,
there was a highway, he could have walked
the highway, you could hear the cars.
Everyone just made a
spectacle out of this kid.
I mean the kid got out because eventually
you go, man, I just get it out of this.
This is horrible. Everybody just
thinks I can't. And so yeah.
So this question is actually is
actually a decent question because that
definitely does play a big thing.
So for me,
and it's the basis for a lot of
nicknames on the team. True, true,
true. Yeah. If you do something
that's um, excessively stupid or,
or just have bad luck, like one of
my favorite ones is Bush, you know,
Bush Acos. Yeah. But he,
he like was parachuting and when he first
got to the teams as a new guy and he
and in his parachute and
he landed in, uh, in, uh,
what kind of Bush was just some kind
of a Bush with thorns and whatsapp.
Parachute got all tangled up and he got
stuck in there. The guys that's name,
he's great too.
He's an awesome Bush full of things.
There's team guys where you don't even
know what their real name was. Actually,
I was kind of like that. Nobody knew what
my actual name was. Mine was just Jocko.
And that would just, that was my civilian
nickname that my parents gave me.
But the funniest was there was a guy,
and I'll just tell the story,
there was a guy and you know him cos I do,
but uh,
but anyways,
his name was Al and I was only,
yeah, I know. It was like,
you know, I knew it was Al and then
he was a heavy weapons instructor,
so we called him big owl and then we
called him big Al 50 cal and it was cow
bell golfing. I knew big outfit
decal for like eight years, right?
And one day I'm like, ah, you know,
we're talking and I were doing some,
we're going on a trip or I knew his name
because I was in a couple of platoons.
I do paperwork,
I finally get to Pittsburgh.
I finally gets a paperwork with him. This
guy was also a real quiet guy. I mean,
real professional, real quiet.
He's off, didn't say much.
And one day I'm doing the
paperwork and I go, hey man,
I'm like looking at the list of
people that's going, I go, hey man,
I thought you were going on this trip with
us. And he's like, he's like, yeah, yeah,
I'm going. And I go, Oh, you're not
on the manifest here. And he goes, no.
And he comes over, he points out his name
and his name is Keith. Yeah. And I go,
I go, I go, Bro. I go, well, your
name is Keith. I go, you want it?
That's a mistake. You don't want me
to get a change? And he goes, no, no,
that's my name. And I go, well,
I thought your name was al. I go,
is Al your middle name? And he goes,
he goes, no, Al's not my name at all.
And I go, I go, Whoa,
Whoa, what do you mean,
why does every single person call
you out? And he goes, well, he goes,
well, in my first platoon, I know I
was out doing something. It was night.
And I was, I would guess I was looking
around and moving my head a lot,
like an hour.
And so the guys started calling me
owl and then over the next platoon,
that changed from Al, just
Murphy into owl owl, the owl.
And then his name was out.
And I literally would have told
you this guy's name was al.
And he never corrected. He just said,
you know, hey, whatever you call me, Al,
that's close enough.
So that BF or somebody named Amanda.
So that's big Al 50 cal.
Uh,
but you know what his reputation was.
Cause there was a
question about reputation.
His reputation was awesome
cause he was solid. He was a,
he was a former marine one
day. Uh, I was, he, no,
that was two, nine, five. Oh okay.
Cool. Nine five was in Nicola. Uh, but,
but you know, solid reputation. So
for me, and I, I guess, I mean it's,
it's what you do operationally
is what builds your reputation.
And if you're a good shooter,
if you're not, you know,
shoot shooting like an idiot, I'm
not put, you know, if you can patrol,
well if you have good field craft, all
those things, they'll real things right.
It's kind of cool.
That's what's kind of cool.
That's one thing that's
in the teams that's,
that's hard for them to erase is what's
your real reputation as a real operator,
as an operator, team guy. That's the
thing that all these people that,
that kind of come and go in the
teams that it's, maybe it's not,
they're not real real team guys.
You can't fake that. You know?
And when guys get some guys
get shot blown up, you know,
wounded and southern
can't operate anymore.
It's not like we throw them to the wolves,
they want to stay in the teams.
We keep them and take care of them and
some become phenomenal instructors and
just go on and do great things. Yeah. I
had the, they were going to keep there if,
if Ryan job would want to stay, they
were going to keep them Acos. Yeah.
Oh you're blind. Cool. Yeah, I've
worked for great, great can lead PT.
You doesn't mean you can't listen
to me when I say go do this.
Yeah. Awesome. And then contrary to that,
obviously the killers are when you, uh,
when you screw up stuff operationally.
And the other thing is if you're an
arrogant, egotistical guy, you'd be,
everyone's going to
hate you. That's, yeah.
And you ain't gonna last
long because if you're,
cause there's some guys that are great
skill wise, they're great operators,
but they're horrible to work with. They're
arrogant, they don't listen to anybody,
they're not humble. And those guys
will have a bad reputation too.
They got blinders on, they can't
open the, you know, and you got to,
if you want to evolve at all, they'll
stay alive, you know? Yup. Yup.
All right,
next one.
What makes a great NCO and for
those of you not in the military,
an Nco as a noncommissioned officer.
The military is broken
into two basic basic,
uh,
pathways of advancement and of existence.
There's officers who are like the managers
and the leaders and then there's the
enlisted guys,
which are the grunts.
But then as they get
promoted through the ranks,
you eventually become what's
called the senior enlisted advisor.
And if you don't,
if you think about Hollywood movies,
the way they always categorize these
two is you got the young junior officer
fresh and Vietnam fresh
out of the academy.
And then you got bused salty old gunnery
sergeant. That's the two. That's the two.
So the ends,
the NCO is the,
is the enlisted side of that and a Nco is,
they always say is like the backbone of
the, of the Marine Corps, the NCO, the,
the chiefs run the seal teams is the, is
the statement, right? Because the chiefs,
the guys that chiefs in the guys,
that'll will be at a seal team,
especially in the old days,
be it a seal team for eight years.
So you are the continuity
and you get raised.
So the question is what makes a great
NCO and who is or was the best Nco?
No. Well for me, what makes
a great NCO or chief is,
I don't think you can just do it.
I think it's a,
I'm not saying I'm a great NCO,
but I did have great Nco who taught me a
lot and they brought me up and they put
their foot square in my
rectum when I needed it.
And they also took their time to explain
things to me when they could see in my
eyes. I was nodding my head yes,
but I was really, I didn't grasp it.
And they're like, I'm going to do it
this way. And they would work around my,
for lack of better word,
learning disabilities.
Cause I mean some of this stuff you
can't know when you're a new guy who just
like, yo Yo yo, she borrowed the chief
and they're like, no, dummy, relax.
Here's how you're doing.
And that leadership style when a long
way with me and uh, I never forgot it.
You know,
who's the best Nco you had or ever known?
Man,
there's so many guys that it's not one
and I can't say their names because you
know, it's not cleared. I mean, but that's
a good thing about nicknames sometimes.
You know, I think, uh,
I'll have to say overall a mister fac
was probably the best one I ever had and
he was just an old school,
hot ass son of a bitch.
But he was fair as all hell.
He was fair and you always knew where
you stood with them. And I love that.
That's what I tried to do later on.
Like,
I didn't want to go hide,
hide,
hide and then totally taken
other direction and just
be like easy on the guy.
So they like me,
you know I don't care.
And I thought that was much
easier in a better way,
cause mission men as how
he should look at things.
Put the mission first and
take care of your man.
But sometimes if you have to sacrifice
men and you've got to like, okay,
you got to die for this mission.
All right Roger, that you don't get.
I mean that's the way the military is.
That's what you get paid for. But yeah,
Mr Fac was probably the best one for me.
Yeah.
So that's another,
when I talked about you and me coming
up in the teams and hanging out with the
same people and being the same,
but we were going to plan together but
we did have the same guys that raised us.
The same guys raised us both
and for sure Mr fat as you,
you are calling him a was
a huge influence on me.
I'm eating a huge influence on me.
Everything I was or am it everything I
was in the teams like as far as being
professional and like,
hey, we're going to look.
That all was taken from Fac I
hell of it was taken from him.
I'm 100% neutral and the seriousness
that he put towards the job,
like the,
the,
the gravity that he put towards the
job and the gravity to put towards the
operational stuff that we just
talked about as far as, you know,
the things that we said
makes up your reputation.
That's what he cared about above anything
else. That's what he cared about.
And so for sure working for
him and that's, that's again,
that's why when we actually
started working together,
and I'm just realizing this right now,
I mean I guess I made sense of it before,
but when we started working together,
that's why we had the same thoughts
and things. Everything was like,
of course we're going to do that. It's
like when we're bounding back one time,
somewhere in Iraq and just, we didn't
even have to say anything to each other.
We're just like cover
and move. Go, go, go.
But one thing real quick, but
NCO, one of the best I ever had.
Another see daddy of mine and I can
say his name cause rest in peace.
Tim Farrell. Tim Farrell was a big,
big influence on my life. I mean,
he was who he was a wicked good operator.
I can't,
I don't know anybody as a
tougher guy in the teams.
He's just a hard hitting guy and just,
he's a really good dude,
man. Really good guy. And he was awesome
at every, everything, everything. Yep.
Yeah. Good. He was an
awesome at everything he did.
He'd beat you at everything.
He would beat guys in the swims and he
wasn't wearing fins and they were just
incredible athlete. Yeah. Incredible
athletes in by the way use. He would,
it's not like a guy that
was like, well, you know,
I didn't get my workout in
today's, no, no, no, no, no.
He didn't care about anything
son of a gun. He was like, oh,
just just get after it
yet. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tim Farrell for sure. It was a
great guy. What a frog man. He was.
He certainly was.
All right.
Anything about accuracy of fire
in combat versus volume of fire.
And I'll tell you the reason I left
this one in here, Tony is a lot,
lotta lot of soldiers and Marines and
team guys that I hear from all the time
and they always are listening.
And not only that at this point,
and I hate to say it,
but in America are our police forces
need to start thinking about this kind of
stuff because there's bad stuff happen
in America where guys are getting in
legit. Yeah. Urban Warfare.
And so talking about the accuracy
of fire versus the volume of fire.
Well you know it's a double is a flip of
the coin on. Depends on the situation.
But I can tell you the number of times I
fired a rifle and assault rifle like an
m four m 14 and all that,
you know,
sky on full auto is
big frigging goose egg.
You know, I, I can't think of one
situation or if somebody said, okay Tony,
you're going in this room alone and
there's eight guys pointing guns at you.
Well, okay, barrage that. But you
know, but sometimes, you know,
volume of fire to get heads down,
if you're in the street,
you got to get that fire. You got
to try to gain flyers, superiority.
And if you don't have that, you
ain't really moving. And uh,
so at that point you're now,
you're not doing all the things
you were taught breathing,
you're just getting led down
in that direction. It's a
cover your ass, your ass.
Well your buddy's ass so you
can move and they can move.
MMM.
But accuracy, firing, combat,
you know, in good situations,
if you're under fire and you're putting
lead down range so you can move,
it's real nice to have a supporting
element in an elevated position.
They're the ones combining these two.
And just as a pretty good example is
pretty nice knowing about four blocks from
you. You got Chris Kyle up there
talking to you on the radio. Hold on,
let me see a guy fall. I like the
window with a gun. You're like,
thanks brother.
Yeah,
you're pretty confident walking down
the street and at that point, so
yeah. Yeah. The, uh,
the other thing is, I mean we
always have massive, you know,
fire power with mark 48, some are 46 is
to lay down the heavy volumes of fire.
And that's the same thing.
Uh,
Roger Hayden was saying in here the
other day who's another that mentored you
and me growing up in the teams and uh,
but he said that they
had for sixties in there,
14 man puts in like two stoners,
three no for sixties and five stoners.
That's, that's what he said. That was what
they carried. And uh, yeah, so, so eight,
you know,
what's interesting to the point,
like we talked about
points or any but the guys,
like all of our guys are aaw owners put
sites, put the [inaudible] on there,
on there. Oh yeah, yeah.
Which was partially for Pid,
so they could tell who they're
shooting at, could see further,
but also man accuracy. Yeah. It's
a four power scope. Yep. You know,
and then at night it don't matter cause
you're using an app peel or a laser and
you're on nods. Anyway, so, so,
and then one last thing is that you,
you know,
again now where you're talking
to a aimed at police officers,
but also also guys in combat,
you don't have unlimited ammunition.
So you gotta think about that to me.
Me and my brother just had his
conversation and uh, you know,
he was like, wow, I wish I
could, you know, concealed
weapon and carry, you know,
he's got,
I got my revolver and he's got
like a six 86 stainless p or plus,
you know, seven shot three
of 37. I wonder where he,
he wanted the revolver. I told him what
to get. Yeah, that's it. That's the thing.
He loves it, but he's like, you know,
Shit like when I'm concealed carry,
should I carry some speed
loaders? I'm like, well, chum,
is that always convenient
now? Well, you know what,
you're not getting in a gun fight.
You're not,
if you're getting somebody shooting,
you either shoot him or do you put down
fire and you run. It's not your fight.
If some of the Jack and your
Chi or whatever, and they
pull a gun, you shoot him.
Yes, but you know, it's a
nightclub shooting or something.
You're blasting your way
out of there and that's it.
You're not going to sit there and you
don't have an unlimited ammo. Right.
And even the teams we didn't,
that wasn't my biggest fear.
I would hate to die of lack of shooting
back and then we'll just suck, you know.
And we never really did run out.
We've got low,
we've got low a few times but
never really run out. It's scary.
That's why we kind of
train on, uh, you know,
we did a lot of that where try to
set a standard, you can't, you know,
if you've got to shoot, you shoot. If
you run out then you go to your pistol.
If you run out of that and you go to
your grenades or whatever and then you'd
just BTF. But uh, but
we trained, you know,
if you're in sustained fire
flights, like m gun is, you know,
after four mags,
you going to start slowing it down,
start thinking about round
congress conservation.
Same thing with the machine gunners.
Start slowing your rates,
fire down initial burst, initial volleys.
And then go down to like, you know,
shorter bursts,
more time looking at what you've seen
because if you're out there hanging with
you guys, hanging, you know, and
you've got no rounds, then guess what?
It's run time and nobody wants to run.
That's just,
just [inaudible].
Awesome. All right, uh, next one.
What is Tony's perspective as an enlisted,
an older guy serving quotes
under you as a younger officer?
So I don't know if this person actually
understands that we're about the same
age and had been in the teams about
the same all the time. And um,
we were more brothers than like
anything else. And then, uh,
what was it like,
what were you like to work for compared
to other guys that you were under? Well,
that first pat at first path is pretty
easy cause I remember you in life with
talking like we didn't know who this
y'all co guy was and I kind of was walking
by the office.
It's like a movie where I stopped like
halfway through a step and I backed up
and I went, what did you guys say? Yeah,
this new Wa Gosh, screen commander,
we don't know who he is, what's his
name if like Ah, Willink, Jocko, Jocko,
Jocko or something like that.
I'm like, yeah, we're all set.
And then they're all like,
you know,
cause they're the two lieutenants Seth
in life and you're like following me into
the head and like, relax.
What about about this car?
Let us like, we're good to go. I might,
we share, we're getting him. They're like,
oh yeah, it's done. He's just
comment and you'd be like,
tomorrow. I'm like, Yup, Yup.
All right, let me just tell you
something. Be squared away tomorrow.
And I started walking away, you know this
guy. And I was like, you know, is he,
is he good to go? And I
just looked at, I went,
I gave him that look like pulleys.
I know what I'm talking about.
The squared away and you
better be on your game. Me,
I'm going to be hung over tomorrow
whenever I've known him forever. But that,
and uh, what were you like to
work for? What you were like,
ah, this not even a question. It was
great. It was the best hour. I mean just,
I don't know.
We think we think the same.
We were likeminded and uh,
we like,
we like to work, we really, really love
their jobs and our men and our people,
you know, and I hate saying I love
my man, that sounds kind of whatever,
but I, you know, I did,
I really cared about the guys and that
was the best part of being a team guy.
And I'm sure Jocko will back me up on
that. Absolutely. As your brothers. Yeah,
there are no doubt about that.
No doubt about that at all.
Um, all right, next one,
please expound on the early days when
you and Tony were new guys in the tea.
This is like a whole
nother podcast. Uh, okay,
go ahead. Well, uh, I don't know,
it was kind of a different time
when we were in new guys. Like wait,
my first platoon, we were involved, you
know, like the first Gulf War and
I thought it was great, you know,
we really didn't do much. My
petunias and, and you know,
some of them guys over
there for six months.
Then the war started and it was like a
month or whatever and then it was done.
Right. You know. But other
than that we, I think
in the later stages in my career,
we didn't train as hard.
But the deployment,
I mean we still trained hide but the
deployments where a hider like more work
and
back then if you did a deployment
where it was like a training deployment
because there was no war going on, we
still had to deploy. If you don't realize,
if there's no wars team guys are
still deploying to same optempo Yup.
And cause we need constantly be around
the world in case something happens.
And uh,
but we did a lot of like hard core shit.
Like we did a lot more
reconnaissance work,
which meant we didn't have vehicles.
So we had lpcs which are leather personnel
carriers and boots and we'd hump in
like 25 clicks or whatever and we'd do
these ridiculous swims and he's long
dives and do all, I mean really like
long, like the hotter the better.
I mean you look at a team to,
to put it in perspective,
you look at a team guy back then a lot
of them were a lot leaner, you know,
and they, we did a lot
more running. Swimming.
You look at like a team area now you
go to the gym and it looks like ww MMA
wrestlers, you know, I mean
they do. Everybody's like,
like stronger and not cause
you got to carry more shit.
We do do a lot more direct action stuff.
But also we did a lot of drinking and
partying and the file in San Diego.
We did, I know that. And
uh, we hung a lot together.
Nobody was married, you know, I don't,
we had like 16 guys in my platoon.
One was married and he was the
Lto. Yeah. Like no one was mad.
We all hung out together all the time
and we all like lived in imperial beach.
They're like Chulavista now people live
like 40 miles away and like everyone's
married and owns a house. Nobody owned
the house. We didn't have any money.
His boxes. Yeah, we, yeah,
we had a house like five guys in an
apartment was like one, one couch.
It was just the disaster.
Yeah. The, the,
the guy that you were talking about
earlier that I lived in the corn auto with
and uh, for quite some time we
had, we, in our house we had,
we only had one fork, so it'd
be like, it'd be like, hey man,
are you almost done with the fork?
Cause I don't want to be out that
couldn't go to Vons and buy another four.
[inaudible] you two gorillas.
That was,
that was 27 when I,
when I remember one of the big things
I remember about checking team one was,
was just not even looking people
in the eyes because he was this,
this reputation and in of just, you're
just going to get beat down. Yeah.
Well you got hazed a lot. Yeah.
We got beat up. We got hazed.
And you didn't,
you know,
you didn't come in there thinking that
the world owed you anything at all. Yeah.
No. The only thing they owed you was
an ass beating. And you know, uh,
we had some big monster
guys at the team too.
I remember I checked in and there
was this one guy who, you know,
probably the biggest guy at team one.
I'm not going to say his name again just
cause I don't want to Jay. Yeah, Jay. Um,
I'm checking it, you know, I'm, I'm,
I'm at the team and I'm doing over there
doing some pushups or something and I
see this guy come out of the gym. He's
literally, how tall is he? Six, six,
six,
six 300 pounds.
Monstrance he's completely covered
in tattoos and he's walking,
it's about a 40 meter walk from the
back of the team, one building to the,
to the area where we keep the outboard
motors and stuff. And he's walking,
he's lumbering,
right?
He's a lumbering along and about 20 meters
into this hike he stops and he's got
a gallon of milk in his hand and
he just stops, like stops it,
uncorked the milk and just sits there
and drinks after gallon of milk,
slowly puts it back down
and puts the lid back on.
And this lumber's the rest of the
way over. I'm like, good Lord,
I hope that guy doesn't eat me.
I was like, kill me and eat me.
And so that was, that was definitely the
team. One thing when I got the team one,
I w everyone was just big bunch of tough
mean bass and they were getting ready
to kick your ass at any time
on daily base. Yeah. And, and,
and I, I, you know, I think, you
know, nowadays there a war going on,
you know?
Right.
And so the guys have a different kind
of test ahead of them and that's cool.
You know, that's different kind of tests
and it's a harder test and it's, it is,
that's, that's what we, that's
what guys joined the teams for.
So the young team guys that are coming
in freaking bad ass. Awesome. Absolutely.
And I tell you what man,
people say whatever about what they want
to say about the way millennials are
and all this stuff, man. I've been to
some hanging out with some team guys,
especially after some memorials and stuff.
These young frogman,
they're bad ass,
bad ass guys that are ready to die
or kill without question and uh,
so respect and I'm so glad
to see where the team,
the team's maintains that always.
Absolutely.
All right.
If Tony had to write
for the history books,
three top stories of shiny
example of BTF getting after it,
what would they be? Just
give me one. Give me one.
Oh my God. Everything. There's so
many good. So many good ones. Um,
it's hard to say just one
guy, you know, but, uh,
I dunno.
I'm one time when me and a dobber did
that like thousand yards center appeal.
That was pretty hard to contain that it
didn't bother me. That was hard, man.
I mean that was, that was
pretty hot. Like, I mean,
this is a tactic with two guys. There's
two of us bringing up the rear of this,
this extraction, you know, actually yeah.
It wasn't extraction cause it was by foot.
Otherwise it had been an exfiltration,
but we kind of took up the rear.
We started like covering moving and
them guys were just on a dead run.
But we had to stop, go, stop, go
for about like a mile or whatever.
It was just terrible.
I mean,
I was sweating like a teamster man.
I mean I was just,
and cause it was like eight o'clock in
the morning and it's like 110 degrees
out. That was, that was pretty
good. I was a pretty good one.
But I remember getting back
to the old days with that.
We didn't say BTF back then,
but we used to do some horrendous humps,
you know, humping to the civilian
world means like marching,
not marching but patrolling. And it'd
be like, Ooh, do you look at the map?
And we don't, we, we didn't patrol in
the day. So it'd be like, all right,
it gets dark at like 19 hundy.
I'm gonna move out about 1930 and it gets,
I'm going to stop at about zero five
and we got to cover, I don't know,
40 clicks. All right, let's go. And your
hundred pound rucksack, you're like,
really? Okay, let's go. And you think, oh,
I couldn't have been a
plumber or something. I don't
know. I'd be a team guy.
I couldn't have been like wanting to
call it. No, no, no. Yeah. You know,
and you were, you were kind of
talking about this earlier, but, uh,
I remember times where you guys be out
in the field for two or three days and
meanwhile while you're in the field,
we're spinning up another opera,
not another target for
a direct action mission.
And you guys get back and he'd be like,
Hey man, we've got to target for you.
You're rolling out in two hours.
So you know,
you just go to your guys and be like,
all right guys,
change your gear or had an outcome.
You want to load vehicles in an hour and
30 minutes and you see guys just turn
and burn. Yup. Got Nobody
said, Oh really? No,
just do it. You know? And Yeah, my whole,
that platoon that I
had on that deployment,
I mean I'm guys BTF I mean
especially like the sisters' kids,
those guys were, you
know, we had the new guys,
we had the older guys and then we hit
the middle guys, you know, and you know,
you know spazz and a squirrel
and Chucky those guys racks,
those guys are bad ass. I
mean they just, they didn't,
they were the meat kind of of the platoon
and there were the ones that like had
to do like most of the work,
you know,
the new guys helped them and the other
older guys were more of leadership
positions. Yeah. And they still work too.
But these guys worked and they just
said you got Roger to that and just got
after it.
Good dudes after day
guarantee after day after day.
I guarantee all of them guys and I
couldn't keep up with everyone after I
retired.
I guarantee all of them guys are doing
well in their careers because they're
fantastic. I, I do see them
and they are all kicking ass.
Roger that and that's good for sir.
Okay.
How does Tony decide what strategies,
tactics to use on a mission against an
enemy? Curious about your thought process.
Hmm.
Well,
first of all, you gotta figure
out which one we're talking about.
My experience in the savages
that Lee Slade and killed shot.
Ah,
first of all, it's better to shoot someone
in the back. So you know, Olin, you know,
an ambush where you can catch him
walking away from you is always the best.
But front you just BTF and figured out.
Uh,
we were talking about sung sue there.
You know the auto ward?
No,
I thought, you know, he says if you know
yourself when your enemy, you don't, not,
not, no need to fear thousand
battles, whatever. Well,
I know myself pretty damn good and I know
my group pretty damn good and I didn't
have time to read all that.
Stop and figure it out.
So I figured I'd just hate the enemy.
I'll just hate him.
And that hate will fuel my passion
to make the operation as best I can
and work at the best I can and
learn from the mistakes that,
and that didn't work out. But
that's that kind of, when you,
when you got that,
it kind of pyramids down and everything
kind of works itself out, you know,
and you can't be afraid to try
something different because,
and you can't be afraid to bounce it off
people. That's what's great about Jocko.
I would bounce something off of them, you
know, and he'd be like, Yep, that's good.
All right, go now. Now wait a minute.
Cause he wouldn't let it go. You know,
Kinda walk me through this
again, Roger, we're going to
do that, that, that, and uh,
I would also really,
when I let other people run operations
or I would work with other groups,
I would, I would just kind of wait for
when they glanced over something and I go,
Whoa, wait a minute. Okay, go. Now what
are we going to do here? Well, you know,
we're just going to do this. I don't
know. I don't know what that means.
Please explain it to me. Well, and
they hadn't really thought about it.
And that's the little glitch in the
mission plan that's gonna get you killed.
[inaudible] but
you can't, you know, you can't take a
lot of time to plan an ops sometimes.
Sometimes it's like, all right, you know
what an assault here we're going to go,
where are you going strong like cowboys
or we're going to go on the prowl,
we're going to go into
surreptitious entry, be real
stealthy. Sometimes you can't,
sometimes it calls for a straight
up punch him up, you know,
just mix it up and BTF you know,
and that's easy to do cause you
don't get to plan much. Okay,
let's just go over there
and kill everybody. Show us
where they'd go. Yup. Yup.
So I don't know if that answers
that question, but yeah,
I think from my perspective,
I mean in a,
you just kind of made it sound like big,
no big deal.
But Tony was always pouring over
the imagery, looking at the maps,
trying to figure out which angle,
trying to figure out what the best spot,
trying to ask what he's
doing all the time.
Just trying to analyze as much as
he could and make the best plan.
And, and I think also Mandy,
the experience level, you know,
cause like I said,
right? Even even pre war,
pre nine 11 how many freaking ops did you
and I do training ops where we did all
this stuff to a thousand. Yeah.
It's just like over and over.
And so by the time you get there,
it's really,
even though these weren't combat
operations, you get a view.
We learned a lot from them and there was
a little justments we had to make for
sure. But for the most part,
which you've learned how to do,
what you learned how to do was you learn
how to take a group of guys and get
them to do something right. And
when you learn how to do that, okay,
that that's then you okay,
you want us to do this? Cool.
I'd have to take a group of guys
and get them to do something.
It doesn't matter what that thing is,
I can get a group of guys to do something
and that's what's beneficial. Nope.
That's what all that years of
experience helps you out with.
It doesn't necessarily help you.
I mean, it didn't help us with,
with doing the specific mission that,
no, no cussing that cause you can't,
can't cover everything.
No.
I mean at that point I had three years
as an instructor and land warfare and it
was my eight ninth deployment,
the line I'd been, you know,
eight platoons or whatever and
there's not much more. I was gonna,
you know, learn from another six months
of training. I mean, it's pretty much,
I mean, there's no real thing I was
going, wow, I've never done this before.
You know, like, yeah.
Okay. Yeah. All right.
What was the most difficult
thing you ever did as a seal?
When was the most fearful
moment in your life?
Well, I get asked this a lot and
uh, tell you the truth is good.
Nothing to do with, you know, the bombs
in the wars and the killing and stuff.
It's like I never,
ever batted an eye skydiving
or static climbing,
jumping into the water, jumping at
night, never bothered me one bit. No,
not at all.
Never even was scared
at all. But I don't like getting
on the roof. You know what I mean?
Like I hate being a 40 foot
ladder in a man lift. You know,
I worked for a landscaping
companies sometimes repping
the man lifts. Like, man,
this is kind of sucks and I'll admit it,
I'm a little bit afraid
of heights at that level.
And rappelling off a building
one morning in Hong Kong,
you know,
like a 60 story building
and we're repelling off and
then going through a window
and you've got to training,
you get to shoot these targets and stuff.
And I mean it's pretty cold,
but I didn't like it at all.
And this morning it was windy
and the building's actually
moving and I look down,
I'm going on a repel, you
know, I'm edging over the side,
I'm an a on the top of this building and
the people look like raisins, you know,
down there. And I mean that
needle to say, I mean I,
I gotta go to the bathroom and I'm
hung over and I was like, oh my God,
but
I'd rather die than be called a pussy.
I'm going to do it not,
but I'd rather die than be a plus.
So that was pretty much the,
I'll never forget that day.
It was terrible.
The most fearful moment or the most
difficult thing you ever do as a seal.
Retire without a doubt.
100% retire.
And I'll leave it at that.
Yeah,
I hear you.
All right.
Tony's favorite piece of
kit and over Tony's career.
What's, what piece of gear has advanced
the most not including night vision,
which obviously improved up to a bunch.
Well,
I'll get to my favorite piece of gear kit,
but uh,
evolution of Kia gotta be, you know,
there's a couple of things, like I say,
boots, the boot thing is phenomenal.
We get such good gear and boots.
Now also, you got to look
at navigation. You know,
I remember the first gps is we,
we used to call them giant pieces of
shit cause they were like the size of an
ammo crate. They're huge, they're huge.
And they looked like a tele phone
from the Korean War, you know,
and uh, but nowadays they're
just bad ass, you know.
And it would global positioning systems,
I mean, and also communications. Yeah,
I mean your satellite communication
is absolutely fantastic.
And everybody was in the military out
there when we had all the old kicks and
Diana pads.
And then if you remember that HF high
frequency and we did a lot of HF and
stringing up antennas. I'm like, God,
it was terrible. Literally. Yeah.
Literally stringing up,
you know,
80 foot antennas so you could make a
communication shot to some other distant
station. I Morris Code literally
using Morris call. Yeah, absolutely.
Good Times.
But my favorite piece of Kit,
I would have to say is anything
that you get in and drive,
because back in the day we didn't, we
didn't use any mobility. Really. Yeah.
Everything was on foot and it's
like holy Shit. That in the uh,
the 300 win mag sniper rifle suppressed
with a 22 power night for scope on it is
a wicked good piece of kit.
Let me tell you what I mean.
I can read your tee shirt at a
click. That's pretty good. Legit,
legit.
All right,
Tony, what is the number one quality
that allows a leader to lead men into
uncomfortable conditions and succeed?
What's uncomfortable? I guess just
bad scenarios. Tufts situations.
Well I think keep it in your
mind. Mission men, mission men.
Look guys, you're not paid to sit
here and here's what we got to do.
Let's go do it. Yes. Uh,
it's socks sometimes is bad,
but mission man,
if you keep thinking that
that's what we're paid to do.
The bottom line is you follow the orders
of the guy above you and we're team
guys so that line bleeds a lot.
It has a lot of waves in it,
you know, cause he'll be like,
hey, Tony would think what
to do. I don't know Jocko,
let's do this. All right, it sounds
good. But at any given time, if he goes,
Hey Tony, this is what we're
doing, Roger that. And that's it.
Even if it means dying.
Because if you lead by example and you're
humble and you're good to your guys
and you know your guys and you
let them know you, but you know,
wipe their ass and you don't take
any shit from them and they know you,
they'll follow you.
No,
you're humble and you make mistakes,
admit it and move on. And I think that's a
okay.
I know a few of my guys,
probably most of them would
follow me wherever we want,
you know?
And uh,
I guess that's just cause I never changed.
They always knew what they're gonna
get from me. That's about it. Steady.
Yeah. The other, uh,
the other big thing is making sure
people understand why they're doing what
they're doing. Cause
like Tony just said, man,
we were going to have discussions
about stuff and say, hey,
this is why, this is why. Well, this is
why I think we should do it this way.
You know,
it's not just like go and do now.
There are situations of
course where someone goes,
hey, go and execute this now.
Hey, go hit that building.
Hey, take guys over there.
There's times in combat where you got to
make those decisions and you've got to
make things happen and that's
when you've taught. That's what,
that's when the important things that
you just talked about having a Ma just
trust. Like I, I just
had trust in my guys.
They trusted me that if I was
telling him to do something,
it was the right thing to do.
And by the way, if I told Tony,
go take that building over there, and he
looked at me and said negative, not now.
I knew he was saying that to me for
a reason. Yeah. In front of it. Yeah.
There was a reason he was telling me that,
and we're not going to
have that discussion.
Probably don't have time to do it
right. Right now. I'd say, okay,
then we gotta get Outta here and he can't.
Okay, Roger, Roger. And then we'd go.
So man, having that trust,
building up that trust through,
you know, the humility, the
relationship, all that stuff is,
is how you end up with a tight unit.
And that's how you really,
that's how you lead.
Tony, did you have the same
attitude towards death as Jocko?
Where are you prepared to
die? Oh, was I prepared that?
Yes, in a second. Let's get
that over with right away. Uh,
I really didn't have an attitude of
death except for you don't make another
people die. The bad guys then I
didn't care about them. I didn't,
I guess ID humanized him in my mind so
it wouldn't bother me cause it, you know,
cause they're just, they're
just, they're not people.
There's a target and you just
whack them and that's it. And uh,
I was, I was definitely prepared to
die and matter of fact, you know,
I thought that would be like the end
of my career. I kind of, but, um,
I thought it would be the
end of your career to,
um, there was a couple guys in our
task unit. I was not scared of dying.
There was a couple guys
in our tasking it that I,
I did not think we're going to make
it because they were just like,
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I'm going to be given a speech at his
funeral cause he's a fired up young kid
that does not care about, yeah.
Like just not the other way.
For those of you out there, like, Ooh,
like didn't do his job. He was like, yeah,
no, like, like just guys that were so,
so fired up that uh,
yeah.
And like even our guys
that did get killed,
there wasn't one of them where I thought,
oh,
he,
he's,
he wasn't ready for that. Right?
Yeah, he will. Did he want it?
Of course those guys didn't want it.
I would love to have him here.
They would love to be here.
But at the moment of truth,
they, they did what I would, I would
think they would, would've died. Right.
None of them did I say,
oh, it's a shame or,
or anything like that.
Because those guys had those attitudes
of they were there. They were, they,
they love their job.
They love doing their job.
They believed in what they were doing and
that that's the way it was.
Yeah,
absolutely.
All right.
Tony's view on training, mentoring,
integrating new guys into the platoon.
Yeah. I mean, I've been
on the LPO side of that.
I've been on the not new guy side of that.
I've been on the new guy so that I've
been in the chief side of it. And, uh,
I usually told the guys, you know,
you're on time, be motivated because
it's fun.
For those of you that think like the
seal teams to me is a thousand times more
than I thought it would be. It's a
fucking blast. It's the best thing ever.
It's the best men's Club
in the world. And, uh,
but like you said,
you're trying to build these guys,
have these guys build their own
reputation, you know, confidence.
Nobody has any confidence in the
first day at the team. Nobody, um,
try to instill confidence in them.
And, uh, I used to tell him, you know,
should be seen, not heard. Carry a pen and
paper beyond time and shut the fuck up.
Nobody cares about any stories,
where you from or none of that crap,
you know,
saint stripes
eventually that'll come out
in a year, you know. So just,
just ask questions. If you
need to be on time, listen,
do your job and uh,
show the guys the right way to do things
and it's not the right way, you know,
tell them how to know the difference.
Show them how to know to do
what they did for me. You know,
and they look and you look in their eyes
and they're just like Roger, but no,
you don't get it. You have no
show me what I just said. Okay.
Just say you don't understand. You know,
but that's about it was tried to be, uh,
you know, fair with them. Direct.
That's about it. We'd by example,
one thing I want to say
there is about, uh, you know,
talk about being steady.
We had a situation one time I was,
I was a platoon chief and we're
working hide, wicked hard,
like going optempo was through the roof.
The battle rhythm was shot to hell
because it was just go, go, go, go, go.
And the guys are getting tired and stuff.
And we had a meeting about it and I
didn't say anything. And I'm like, yeah,
if we can just slow down a little bit,
you know? And I was like, okay. I mean,
well Gitelman bitch. Cause
sometimes you go, go, go.
Like that thing's getting safe
and you start making mistakes.
But we hadn't really made any
mistakes at that point. And I said,
put it in perspective at this time,
like Dava some of them guys,
like 2123 years old,
I was like 38 and I go,
I use the analogy like we used to say,
you're only as fast as the
slowest guy in your patrol.
Maybe the guy that's got more
weight carrying more equipment.
So he sets the pace and I go, I'm
gonna go though. You agree with that?
And everyone's like, yeah, yeah.
Well we'll take a break when the oldest
guy here gets tired and that's me and
I'm not tired enough, said, okay, Roger
that go to work. They're just like,
yeah, Roger. So
hopefully some of the new guys
learned something on that one. Yeah,
yeah, no doubt about that. It's a
leading from the front, you know,
if, no doubt about it. All right.
How does one put the high of war behind
him and his eat any and are you always
searching for it still in other things?
Uh,
have I transitioned to civilian life?
Kind of ish. A little. I just
don't like as well. I mean it's,
it's terrible. Like there's
no action. I mean there's no,
you don't go in and who didn't like
going to work on a Monday morning? Yeah,
it was the best. I mean,
and you know on that,
and by the way, you went to work on
Sunday, you went to work on Saturday?
Just every, every, oh, like some of
the guys that the team will, Oh yeah,
it's a weekend. No, we'll be at the
team. We're going to be working out.
Then we were working on our gear.
They're already grabs a beer and
then we're going to go out there.
We're going to wake up the next morning
and do the same thing on Sunday and they
were to come in on Monday.
That's what it is. Yeah.
Because who cares about what
else are you going to do?
What else are you going to do?
Like, Oh, you go with your friends,
with your friends. All my friends are
in the teens, so it gives you nothing.
So, oh, see that's it. Go back to
whatever failed relationship I had.
Yeah. So, uh, that can
definitely be a little tricky.
Am I searching for another
things? Probably, you know, uh,
I don't know.
That's such a hard question
to put in perspective. I mean,
I live in New Hampshire now and I work
40 hours a week and I do all right.
But I don't, there's no, you know,
the magic in my life is like gone. I
mean, that was, that was the magic,
the glue that held me together as
the teams, you know, and, you know,
I got some good families back there,
you know, that, that helped me out.
Like friends of mine, friends of my
family, and like the Murphy's, you know,
the Daniels, the downs is, I mean,
there's just, it's, if, you know,
if I don't get to people back
home's name, I'm sorry, but, uh,
you, I got really good friends
that try to help me kind of,
but they just have no
idea. Like, you know,
there's one old team guy from back
there that's from the 70s, you know,
and I talked to him and it's like Roger,
you know,
then there's a sergeant major
retired 30 meters back there,
but it's a small town and it's like,
I drink a lot and you know,
I work a lot too, so I'm kind of
functioning that way. But there's no,
I dunno, I guess, I guess
I'm still looking for something, but
it's just the high wars, just like,
I don't know, it's, I
think he could say it's
the fucking best. It's like
the best thing ever, you know?
And once you get done with
a big firefight, like, yeah,
you want to go back and like, can we
do that again? And again and again.
It was so much fun. I mean even, I mean,
it's socks. It's hard, but it's, it's,
it's great. I mean, I would
just, cause if you think about,
like they say heroes, right? Tell me.
The real heroes are then guys standing
up post out there with minimal training
that don't want to be there and still
do their job and find American soldiers,
sailors, marines, you know, airman,
whatever. For us, that's our profession.
Like, you know, that's like,
we didn't even want to go home.
It's like our blood in our guts. It's in
our DNA. That's where we want to be. So,
I mean, how do you, you don't just, you
do all that stuff for all those years,
there's going to be side effects. You
know, there's gonna be, I don't care. I'm,
you know, I'm not going to go, I
don't go see a counselor or nothing.
Cause I think I'm strong enough that, you
know, I can handle it, but it's not easy.
You know, it's like when
people, when people always
come up and they say, you know,
thank you for serving.
Yeah. They always say that.
I know, you know, say, Hey,
it was an honor to serve course,
but what I really want to say,
and sometimes if it's a deeper
conversation, I'm like totally fake me.
I feel guilty because you do enough.
And like you guys paid me to do this.
Like what did you do
when you're a little kid?
I ran around the woods and played
military stuff and ray put camouflage,
put cold black cork on my face and
played with guns and beet shot BB guns.
And that's what I did
all the time as a kid.
And then I grew up and I turned 18 and
then they started paying me money to do
the same thing. And then they said,
oh, there's a bunch of bad guys.
You go kill them all. Okay there we'll
give you more money. And then, yeah, so,
so people say thank you and it's Sorta,
it definitely makes you feel like,
damn man, I got so lucky the
day I enlisted in the military,
I got so lucky because it was like,
you know,
it was like the square peg
found the square hole basically.
And that's what a lot of team guys are
like and that's why when all of a sudden
this score, they go, okay, you can't
use that, that square hole anymore.
They pull you out and
there's a triangle there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Out.
Yeah, it's so true. And they, the service
to me, I wanted, when I was eight,
I listen when I was 17 when I, when
I was 18 got out when I was, what,
45 44 whatever.
And it never lied to me.
They always paid me and they'll
pay me for the rest of my life.
And everything they said was
true, do this. They go, oh,
the mood to use a bunch of
bullshit. There's little
things. But overall, you know,
I didn't have to like figure out,
figure out like a woman and it was all
wishy washy about shit and stuff and you
know, and all that's just part of
whatever, being a man and stuff.
But they never lied to me. It was
always just really, really good.
Civilian Life's not like that. I mean, I
deal with people and for the most part,
everybody out there as a good person,
I believe.
But I get mad because of the
misuse of the military. Now.
I mean it's so misuse.
It's crazy.
Grab 200,000 bad-ass army soldiers and
Marines go over to where Isis is and
smoke these sons of bitches.
What are we waiting for?
I don't get it cause, but on
the flip coin, people were like,
we get to pay the deficit because we
don't want our children to pay it. Yeah.
But do you want them to fight the war?
Let's go. We got the muscle right now.
I don't know what we're waiting for.
This is a crock of shit.
Hopefully they'll change.
Hopefully we'll change.
Uh, you know what? We'll
do one more question here.
How do you keep your head in the game
when one of your squad is killed?
Okay.
Yeah.
You know,
well,
I think for me,
you have to treat it like
mission men in that order.
And to me that there's no use. You
know, the milk is on the floor.
There's no use crying over it.
You know. Eod doesn't, you know,
diffuse a bomb that already went off.
Okay,
well you gotta do is try not to
lose any more your man. Okay,
now you just got to do the
mission with the dead guy.
And I know that sounds maybe cruel.
So there ain't no time to sit
there and mourn or do any of that.
You have to complete your op, you
have to do your mission, right. Um,
there's plenty of time to mourn.
There's front of the time to figure out
what went wrong or what didn't go wrong
or whatever happened when
you're back at the ops done.
And that's why we train like that when
we train and we going through a building
and they put a guide down, you just
step over him, clear the house.
Cause you don't want to get no more than
one killed and you just have to do what
you've been trained to do.
And then the leadership position,
it's very hard not to, you know,
you can train all your life,
but when something happens like that,
it's very hard not to just go, oh my God,
I've got somebody killed. You
know what happened, what happened?
Cause I take it very personally because
it was one of my guys and I racked my
brain for a long time. And
then, uh, I figured out that,
well, you know, I just got to do
my job and be a leader, you know,
and I can't let the rest of the guys down.
I can't let myself down
and my team and my country.
So I got to do what I gotta do to get
Outta there and not get out of there,
but complete the op
and then figure it out,
then take care of him as best we
can and have a lot of respect.
And that's about the best way
I can answer that Bro. Yeah.
You know,
I,
I remember a pastor mark got
killed and he was obviously,
he was the first seal killed in Iraq.
He's the first guy that ever
worked for me that got killed. And
I remember a couple of days went by,
we actually did the memorial ceremony,
um,
in like a couple days went by and I was
kinda trying to figure out what to say
to the platoons specifically what
to say to your platoon. Right.
And I was sort of a,
and I realized what I was doing right
when I was doing was the only thing I knew
how to do, which is work. Yep.
And finally I remember I
was, I wrote, that's what I,
that's what I wrote down and be like,
look,
mark came into your platoon and I said,
hey,
mark is the best motherfucker
ever. Yeah. He will.
And My fucking soul is crushed right now.
And actually remember as I was talking,
I started getting emotional
and
I stopped and I was
getting a little choked up
and I stopped talking.
I was just trying to get it together.
And you were sitting there and
you're like, hey man, it's okay. Yup.
And I was like,
check,
this is what I'm going to
do. I'm going to work. Yep.
And this is what we're going to do.
I'm going to work. We're going to work.
You know when that happened,
I was thinking about that.
I,
I never ever once shed one tear and I
started getting like concerned like do I
have anything they feelings at all.
And then we came back from
that deployment. I remember
maybe, I don't know,
six months later, something, it may
not sound like it may shock you, but I,
I used to like cats. I used to like cats,
you know, you always seem like a cat guy.
I like dogs too.
You know,
like just me and my girlfriend the time
had cats and my cat died and I bawled
like a little baby for like three hours.
And it just,
I think it was just a point in me
waiting for him to come out, you know?
And it'd be like, okay, cause you're a
team guy around that stuff all the time.
People getting maimed shot,
killed and blown up and you know,
and then it kind of festers
in that I think, you know,
it's kind of deep and stuff, but whatever.
I'm not really that deep of a person.
And it just came out and I was like,
you know, that's kind of cool. Yeah.
So maybe I was just,
you know,
I took the like beehive
thing a little too, too,
too much.
Probably.
Well,
I think that's about all
we've got for tonight and, uh,
thanks everybody for asking
those questions. Tony,
you've got any got anything else you
want to say? Any closing comments? Nah,
just shout out to all my,
my chums and all my brothers
in the teams and you know,
all the people that know me,
my family and everybody.
And thanks for being so
nice to me and the teams.
Thanks for being so nice to me and letting
me do all those wicked cool things,
you know? And uh, Jocko. Thanks fab me.
It's so good to see you, my brother. Oh,
echo pleasure too. I mean,
just, just phenomenal. You know,
you don't know how many people
watch your show a watch this. Well,
what fires me up the most is,
uh,
obviously the military guys and the
team guys and a team guys that are,
you know, are bros that are like,
hey man, that was great. Oh yeah,
I learned and that just gets me, uh,
that's why I'm doing this, man. Yeah.
That's why I'm doing
this. And yeah, that's,
that's what means the most to me and
having you on here obviously is, uh,
is phenomenal. So, um,
everybody that is out here
that's listening to this,
thanks for listening to the podcast.
Thanks for supporting it.
If you do want to support
the podcast a little bit,
Echo Charles, tell them
quickly had it do it. Actually,
actually, I do have one more
question. Go ahead and win. Um,
you know how Kate, you're like a
hard guy and as put real simply in,
this might be kind of an ambiguous
question, but like that example,
you say it was real hot and
you're not even drinking water,
you're drinking coffee and Copenhagen.
Yeah. Example. Like, why is that?
You know how, because it's a
spectrum, right? Like a lot of people,
like some people, they can be big, they
can run, you know, 10 miles, no problem,
all this stuff,
but they get in certain kinds
of discomfort physically
or whatever they're done.
Or you get these big guys or whatever,
they'd missed one meal. They're done.
They're thoroughbreds. Yeah.
So you're like, are you like,
I was part of that crew in the teams,
like fist fought and drank a lot.
And so that kind of trained us like
being hung over and stuff. Like,
I mean we would be like hung over and go
work and you work out for three hours.
Yeah. So these guys was, I knew guys
would like, they could never do that.
Right. So we're kind of like
bottom feeders, so on shit
got bad, we're like, eh,
whatever.
Yeah, I'll, I'll, I'll make it. I'm
not like that anymore. Like I work,
I need to drink water because
I'm not used to it. I would,
there was some kind of a genetic
component like, right. Like, like I,
I freely admit, like I
don't sleep a lot. Right.
And I understand that it's not just cause
like I'm just toff it's cause there's
some genetic component in there that
doesn't require a lot of sleep and either.
And you know, I have one of my taught
told us before, like one of my daughters,
I'll go to bed at like 1130 she'll be
awake and then I'll wake up at four 31 and
she'll be awake. Like she's genetically,
she doesn't need a lot of seats.
So I know,
I'm Kinda like that too.
And there's just Fyi for Tony,
there's something genetic about
the water intake because I mean,
I did patrols and stuff
with you and you know,
I mean I'm fairly hard,
but I need water, you know,
I would need to carry more water
than you and you know, never,
never would I be like a bitch about it.
Like,
but no. You know, I, I,
I would need like twice as much water
as Tony would eat and I don't wait twice
as much.
I mean,
I'm whatever I may be for you 40
pounds heavier or something like that.
But so there's some genetic component
that makes you need less water and makes
me need a decent amount
of water. So again,
also I spent a lot of time at nylon. Yeah,
yeah, for sure. You're acclimated to,
I'm not like that now.
I need a lot of water.
But even even overall above and
beyond just the water situation where,
and you're like this tool that
we're kind of talking about this,
where do you think that,
you know,
like if you just sit around indoors
and after awhile you're like Bro,
I got to get out. Oh yeah. A lot
of people, they're not like that.
They're the opposite. There was like,
Dang, there's a lot going on outside.
I'd better stay indoors. Even big,
tough, strong guys. A of people.
I like that. Is it. And does it,
does this kind of fall in line with
why you took to the team's sole? Yah,
absolutely. Echo now cause you're like
that too. And I'll tell you again,
going back to give credit
where credit's due, man.
The people that we were raised by, the
same people in the teams and those guys,
they didn't complain about anything.
They showed no weakness ever. Ever, ever.
Nothing. Like, Oh, you're
tired. They would net,
you'd never hear a guy say he was tired.
Ever. Never. No. No. Uh, you know, hurt,
doesn't matter. Um, uh, broken something.
No, just be quiet. Put tape on it.
Yeah. Shut up. Yeah. And that's, and
so when you're brought up that way,
and I mean it was blatantly
obvious when you've got the teams,
like if you just know there was no,
no, just don't complain about anything.
Just beat, just suck it up.
Oh, this sucks. Yeah. Don't
even admit that. It sucks.
Don't ever do that.
Yeah. And let's be quiet.
That's probably the best way to
explain it. Yeah. That and like,
I didn't have anything else put that.
Like I said, I wasn't the best shooter.
I wasn't the biggest guy, but
I had that, I always had that.
I remember one time we training and you
know how like after around it's done
like a lot of people and I was one
of those people you just, yeah,
you just flop on your back and lay down
and get your arrests one. Yeah Bro.
One time, long time we'll take your
eyes off your enemies more or less.
The attitude. He was like,
you look a little tired.
They're almost like it was when you first
kind of started coaching me up a lot
and you were like, you look a little tired
there, but it wasn't a joke. It was kind
of like as if you really want it
to say bro, don't do that. Right.
They're like stand up. Walk though.
You're like showing weakness.
Like I don't like how you do that.
That was really the tone that was so
that makes a lot of sense right there.
But that being said,
I think it goes,
I feel like he goes a little bit above
and beyond just having a skill or,
or being really good at being able
to tolerate pain. I feel like,
just like how you were saying, I think,
you know, a few weeks ago you were like,
there is, there is a word, a little bit
of pain to show on my life kind of thing.
Right, absolutely. But like in our
case, I think it can be cat or cat,
our guys is that we are,
uh, we're lunatics. Yeah.
Like massive cause who wants who?
Nope.
Looks there's be a frog man for 20.
I mean that's just pushed
so hard on your body.
But we are lucky. Lucky. But a guy like
Tim Farrell who you talked about earlier,
I mean all them guys that we
talked about, Mr Fac, I mean he,
how old was he when we were coming up
on the teams? He was 46, 47 years old.
All broken, you know, broken
knees, broken ankles. Guess what?
Out there on a six and a half
mile run every single time.
And what were the complaints?
None. Not One. None ever. Just,
just crush everyone and just be
actually like, Eh, like Mr [inaudible],
he wouldn't, he wouldn't crush people
on the run, but you'd see them hobbling.
Yeah, our cross the finish
line and you'd be like,
that had to hurt so bad but he just, well
whatever. Yeah, put a little tape on it.
Well I fell out of a helicopter and
broke my heel bone on Halloween day and I
deployed and well actually I
went over it before deploying it.
So I deployed in March. Yeah, I got,
I got hammered and I cut my cast off
with these bolt cutters and that wasn't a
good idea. And uh, I remember the master
chief and the command he'd, he'd be,
he's like, you want to make sure
it was good to go to go overseas.
Wouldn't be walking down
a hallway and I'd see him.
I'd walked perfectly and it hurts
so bad. He goes, how you doing?
I stand on shit. Shoot the
shit with them from it. Good,
good. Roger. All right. Hey,
I got to go. Go in the bathroom.
You'd go in the head and be like,
I mean I was still hobbling
when we deployed. It just,
it just kind of went away.
There's no way I was missing that.
No Way.
I think most of us are like that maybe
to begin with when maybe taught like out
of it, cause you know, I mean
even in everyday person, if they,
they do something kind of hard
to work out or even, you know,
something like people will,
recreation will be like,
I think going to run a marathon
or something like that.
So when they do something
hard or kind of painful,
some kind of adversity and it's done,
you feel good.
I think that's a natural
thing. Like people like, like
look my cool scar, you know,
that kind of thing.
But it kind of feels like,
and kind of listening and stuff
as an outsider a little bit here,
it kind of seems like those shackles of
kind of being trained out of that just
didn't happen for you guys. And
guys like you, you know? Oh yeah,
maybe we got trained in the other
way quite yet. Or I think you,
you guys just held onto it,
you know? Absolutely. I could
just, yeah, yeah. There's,
there's no doubt.
And there's a bunch of bunch of
Badass frog men that are in the team.
That's all you, you know, you can go
talk to the marines. Army soldiers.
Tough bastard. Kick nuts.
Okay. So when, when he's living
here, we're rolling. Do you,
what's that thing that crow, it's like
this syndrome when you just worked out.
It's called beyond the Rab
Rhabdo rhabdomyolysis. Yeah.
So he gets that by the way. And
He, um, it's just from his role,
his best friend growing up to him,
two of his best friends growing up.
Our team guys, I'll tell you, they are
later. Oh, nice. So He's, we're rolling.
Do you just said, and he's
like going every day. I'll
just, all day, he's like, man,
I'm just doing DJ and he's not, he's
kind of quiet, you know, he's like, oh,
we're all done. We've been done
hard day. Then like, you know,
the guys who showed up later, whatever,
they, they're still kind of, they're like,
hey, you want to all cake? And
I was like, okay, like that.
So he never says no. Okay.
The next week, like, I guess he had to
go to the doctor. What are the next week?
He's like, yeah, you have
that metal. Rhabdo like,
have you been doing a lot of physical
output? You know this? He's like, yeah,
can we can be spin shrieking. I know,
but that's exactly what I'm saying.
But normally that stops
a guy in his tracks while
they're training and he's just
like, no, just keep training.
Someone else wants to try and go.
I remember one time he said, I call
him kinda tired. I mean he said that,
but he didn't say I'm done rolling.
You look tired.
I'm head. Yeah. Awesome.
That's awesome. Uh,
all right. Any other questions from
Echo Charles? That's it. We can, um,
we can go to support, you
know, let's wrap it up.
How can they support if you want to
support this is how you can, you know,
we talk about getting after
it a lot from time to time
and supplementation is not a form
of weakness. Would you agree Tony?
I would agree. Right. Supplement, right.
Best supplements because now that he's
supplements can be kind of whack on it.
Fortunately someone on Twitter
was asking me about, uh,
shooting tech shroom tech, like, oh,
how does it work and all this stuff.
Here's the thing. This
is, I know that it helps,
I've heard from a credible source
that it helps with oxygen utilization.
So you know, like high intensity that
that kind of goes prolonged or whatever.
But you can read on it on the website,
they have all the,
like the actual literature,
like the tests and all this stuff on
all this stuff anyway, so it's legit.
We all know it's legit. I think that's
kind of common knowledge. By now.
You can get 10% off if you want
supplements on it. Duck on. Slash Jocko.
Let's go slash Jocko.
Get a worrier bar as
well. My, my suggestion,
not a good stuff on there.
Next Way Amazon slip,
you shop on Amazon. Like we all
do. Click through the website,
our website Jocko, podcast.com. There's a
little link there, little banner on the,
on the side and uh,
you know,
go through Amazon or go to Amazon through
there and of course subscribe to the
podcast on iTunes and youtube doing
more videos to come by the way.
Yeah.
And of course Jocko store if you like.
Any shirts that we um, we have, we did it.
I think we expended a
lot of mental energy,
making sure that the shirts are good
to go as they say or as you would say,
kind of dope. Dope, dope, dope meaning
not just either dope cause we said,
so we try to put different layers on them,
you know,
and you know how it's not like it just
says hey I'm cool or I don't know,
whatever.
It's,
it says something and then there it means
something as well where if you didn't
know what it means, you just don't know.
That's one layer you don't know about it.
You know,
this one has a couple of layers,
sometimes three just saying they're not
just normal shit and their quality as
well.
Just saying they're good anyway.
You can judge for yourself as
far as how they look. Jocko,
store.com if you'd like.
I'm good.
Get a shirt support that way
or a mug or sticker, whichever.
All rash guard or rash guard.
Yes. So new things, rash guard.
If you didn't know already,
rash guards are good biking,
diving, swimming, surfing,
bodyboarding across fit any kind of
Olympic lifting where you need mobility's,
it's actually better than cotton
shirts. They like, you know what I mean?
And Do Jitsu.
Last but not least to Andy did good
and today Andy on his fight represent,
yeah. It wasn't a super fighter.
A bracket by the way. Oh,
I thought it was [inaudible] decision.
He'll hook.
Dang Andy representing and uh,
yeah,
he did in fact have trooper Russia.
See what we were talking about the 17,
what was 17 to 19% improvement
in performance. Yeah.
And Wow,
it my bro science like opinion.
I think that applies to all
physical activity. When you
were this rash guard. I,
I'm, I'm a believer and for
those of you that don't know, uh,
Echo Charles does have a doctorate
in Bro Science, I'm working on it
and I'm, okay. So the new
stuff, uh, also we have patches.
I have velcro that velcro ones, you
know, like this Guy Catatonia um,
and then women's stuff as well.
Their tank tops. I okay, I got you.
We're going to do tee shirts as well.
Thank you Lisa for the you the nudge,
you know,
and then, um, yeah, there it is.
That's the stuff. Maybe some more,
some more cool stuff. You
know, the seasons are changing,
so we'll put some more stuff on there.
If you guys liked it, gets cold,
need some warm gear, potentially get
it done. Yeah. But there it is. Yeah.
Support and thanks for everyone with the,
the who has supported this dope.
If you want to get some of this
goodness, right, a little bit of a
pomegranate white tea available
on amazon.com Jocko white tea.
The only thing I drink
other than water and milk,
so jump on the train. Also, if you haven't
got a copy of extreme ownership yet,
which me and my brother Leif Babin road,
which has a ton of Tony who you heard
from tonight, a ton of Tony in there.
Anytime you're hearing about the Charlie
platoon chief or Charlie patoot Nunez
or Trump, that's the guy was
running it and making it happen. Uh,
you can pick up the hard copy digital
copy or the audio book and Lafe and I
actually read in October 20th and
21st and San Diego, California.
If you're a leader or
you want to be a leader,
come on out to the
extreme ownership muster.
We were going to teach the principles
of combat leadership and we're going to
get in the weeds on the tactics
of how to actually employ them.
It's one thing to know on,
but you got to know how to employ them
on the battlefield, on the street,
in the business world or in life.
So register and then come and get it.
And as always,
if you want to keep kicking it with us,
Echo Charles and myself were all
up on the Inter webs Twitter,
Instagram and that face bookie,
uh,
Echo Charles is at echo.
Charles, I'm at jockowillink.
I don't think Tony has any
of that stuff too busy.
BTF BTF Dotcom. Yeah. Yeah.
Just don't contact me.
Dot Ca
and uh,
to all the motivated troopers out there,
especially first off
those in uniform military,
law enforcement, firefighters, EMT,
[inaudible], thanks for what you all do.
Thanks for working hard for training,
hard for living hard and for fighting
hard and for holding the line and the rest
of you folks out there,
the rest of you troopers in the work
force attacking your daily struggles,
smashing obstacles,
keep doing what you're doing in
doing it with focus in some ferocity.
And finally to Tony.
Thanks again my brother
for coming on the show.
Thanks for the years you put in training,
fighting and leading.
Thanks for always being there
to support me no matter what.
No matter what.
Yes sir.
Thanks for what you did for me
for the task unit, for the teams,
for the navy and for the
United States of America.
And you know,
Tony is one of the many veterans from
every war who remains in the shadows who
seeks no glory,
who did what he did as his duty
for country and for his brothers
on his left and now on his right.
So to all of you veterans like Tony,
the true quiet professionals,
thanks to you warriors who have set the
example of how to serve and of course,
how to get after it.
Yeah.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
and the original BTF
Tonia Friday. Thanks brother. Ditto.
Nuff said check Roger.
Roger out.